Ah, yes, excellent.
I've had time am Start.
So, Leute.
Es war heute wirklich schwierig, auf YouTube ein paar Sachen zu finden, die man sich angucken kann.
War wirklich nur Schrott dabei.
So wie halt einfach 95% von YouTube nun mal ist, ne?
Jetzt muss ich ein bisschen leiser machen.
Moin.
Ja, also ich muss echt sagen, 90% von YouTube ist so schwachsinnig, was da gibt.
Also nicht mal lustig schwachsinnig, sondern einfach für den Arsch.
So, guck mal.
Wir machen jetzt mal was.
Wir gehen jetzt mal kurz hier auf Trends.
Achso, Moment.
Ich hab mein Dings auf Browser auf Englisch stehen.
Ja, ne, dann nicht.
Ah, doch, hier.
Trending Videos, ja?
What the fuck?
Also Trending, ich weiß nicht, wem das gefällt, was da unter Trending Videos ist.
Meiner mag vielleicht mal da sein oder andere dabei sein.
Aber das war einfach nur übelster Schrott.
Äh, doah.
Residen-Sleeper.
Nein, keine Ahnung.
Kenn ich mich nicht mit aus mit.
Ich glaub, Lancom hatte ich noch nie was in der Hand.
Ja.
Kannst du verwenden.
Ich hoffe sogar, dass sie demnächst vielleicht was rausbringen.
Ohne IPv4, nur mit IPv6.
Dass man kein extra Geld für IPv4 bezahlen muss.
Tribulon, danke schön für den Sub.
Ja, ich war ja gestern.
Ach, Slabberchen.
Gestern, Schwachsinn.
Äh, letzte Woche.
Also nein, diese Woche eigentlich noch.
Das ist ja Sonntag.
Ja, ist Sonntag schon erster Tag von der neuen Woche?
Oder ist Sonntag letzter Tag von der alten Woche?
Wie handhabt ihr das?
Also für mich ist es der letzte Tag von der alten Woche.
Naja, zumindest, ich war ja diese Woche.
Sonntag ist alte Woche, genau.
Ja, ja, seh ich auch so.
Ich war ja irgendwie das dritte Mal oder so auf der Arbeit in Frankfurt.
Und ich hab mir gleich irgendwas eingefangen.
Nicht wirklich.
Nicht wirklich schlimm, aber ich merke das im Hals.
Dass ich irgendwas, irgendwas im Hals habe.
Gleich mal in der Bahn gewesen und irgendeinen Scheiß eingefangen.
Es wird, es wird wahrscheinlich nicht Corona sein.
Weil das ist wahrscheinlich anders.
Außerdem bin ich geimpft.
Vielleicht ist es ja, vielleicht ist es ja Corona.
Und weil ich geimpft bin, merke ich kaum was von.
Keine Ahnung.
Zumindest sagt das richtig.
Ich hab jetzt, ich hab jetzt, ich hab jetzt.
Ich hab jetzt, ich hab jetzt.
gelesen, dass die Dänen
haben jetzt gesagt, Corona gibt es nicht mehr.
Also haben gesagt, ist vorbei
bei uns.
Aber die Dänen haben es eh
drauf, was das angeht.
Ich hatte mal einen Kollegen auf der Arbeit,
der kam aus Dänemark
und eins konnte der richtig gut.
Das war sich, wie soll ich sagen, nicht hetzen
lassen. Doch, habe ich.
Natürlich habe ich das. Ich habe mich zweimal
impfen lassen und das ist jetzt, keine Ahnung,
drei Monate her, äh, drei Wochen
her oder vier Wochen her oder so.
Also, wenn ich jetzt keinen Impfschutz habe, dann weiß ich
auch nicht.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich Corona habe.
Ich glaube, ich habe irgendwas, irgendwas
anderes im Hals.
Man weiß ja nie.
Ähm,
ja. Aber die Dänen haben es eh
drauf. Wie gesagt, ich hatte mal einen dänischen Kollegen,
der konnte sich, der hatte, der hatte echt das Talent
dafür, sich nicht aus der Ruhe bringen zu lassen.
Das Wetter. Das ist
wie mein, wie mein Opa oder
die Oma auch. Mein Opa hat immer gesagt, so nach
dem Motto, genau, so nach dem Motto,
ah, mein Fuß tut weh.
Mein Fuß tut weh. Das liegt am
Wetter. Oder, ah, das Knie tut wieder
weh. Es liegt am Wetter.
Puzzleweise, danke für den
Sub. Was ja kompletter Schwachsinn
ist, ne. Das habe ich damals,
damals habe ich ihm das versucht zu erklären.
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Das liegt nicht am Wetter.
Habe ich ihm versucht, das zu erklären, dass das eher Zufall
ist, wenn das, wenn das übereinstimmt.
Aber nein, nein, nein, da war der Meinung,
er merkt auch in seinem Fuß,
wenn sich das Wetter ändert.
Der hat gesagt, ah, mein Fuß tut weh,
das Wetter wird anders. Und wenn das Wetter
dann anders geworden ist,
dann hat er gesagt, siehste, ich habe es gewusst
und wenn er, äh,
wenn, wenn das Wetter sich nicht geändert hat, hat er gesagt,
das kommt noch. Weil, ich meine, irgendwann
wird sich das Wetter schon in nächster Zeit ändern, ne.
Weltminister, huge subscriptions,
vier Monate hier. Nice.
Gut, das kann ja was mit, äh, ja, Moment,
Moment. Du sagst ja aber nicht, dass du,
Wetteränderung, Tage
oder sowas im Voraus erkennst, dadurch,
dass du Kopfschmerzen bekommst. Du sagst, hey, wenn sich
heute das Wetter ändert, dann kriege ich Kopfweh. Das kann
ich mir schon vorstellen. Aber, der hat
ja gesagt, so nach dem Motto, mitten am Tag, ah, mein
Fuß tut weh, das Wetter wird anders.
So, das war einfach so ein random guess.
Wie hast du die Impfung vertragen? Also,
erste Impfung hatte ich ein bisschen Kopfweh
und war ziemlich müde, so ein, zwei
Tage und mir hat der Arm weh getan, war kein Problem.
Zweite Impfung
war ein bisschen, war im Prinzip genau das
gleiche, nur, nur ein bisschen ausgereicht.
Ausgeprägt. Also, ich hatte übelst Kopfweh
einen Tag lang, so, dass ich gar nicht vor dem Rechner sitzen
konnte.
Aber dann, dann ging's auch.
Der Arm hat mir zwei, drei Tage weh getan,
dann war vorbei. Also, ich hab
überhaupt gar keine Probleme gehabt.
Größere Art, ne,
der mit, mit der Corona-Impfung.
So sind ja, ich hab übrigens, äh,
Biontech gekriegt.
Ähm,
so sind ja gerade am überlegen, ob es
jetzt nicht irgendwie noch eine dritte Runde oder so gibt.
Lass ich auch machen. Wenn das sinnvoll ist,
leuchte es auch.
Lass ich auch machen. Dritte Runde.
In your ass.
Ne.
In den Arm.
Nicht in der Ass.
Ja, ich glaube, das hatten die meisten. Wenn du mal so
nachguckst, Nebenwirkung Corona-Impfung.
Das ist im Prinzip, im Prinzip sagt jeder,
äh, müde und
Kopfweh. Das ist, glaube ich, Standard.
Ich hab in die Ass, aber das ist auch
nicht schlecht, ja.
Verstehen bloß Battlefield 3
Spieler. So, lass gucken,
was wir dann heute machen.
Leute, ich muss, ich muss, ich muss aber sagen,
ihr wisst ja, ihr wisst ja, ich bin alt, ja.
Ich hör mich, ich hör mich vielleicht
auf Twitch nicht so an.
Und, ähm,
vielleicht, vielleicht kommt das auch nicht so rüber,
wenn ich hier was, äh,
von Poggers, Fivehead, sonst was erzähle.
Aber ihr wisst, ich bin alt. Ich bin 37
jetzt, ja. Kann man sich nicht,
kann man sich oftmals nicht vorstellen, aber ich bin 37
jetzt, ja. Okay. Und mir ist,
mir ist, ich hab mir da letztes Mal Gedanken drüber
gemacht. Zufällig. Weiß nicht.
Ich glaub, als ich auf dem Klo war oder so.
Weißt du, bester Ort, wo man
sich, wo man sich Gedanken macht.
Zumindest, ähm,
was mir aufgefallen ist.
Auf dem Klo.
Also, was mir aufgefallen ist,
dass eigentlich 1984
das beste
Geburtsdatum überhaupt ist.
Wisst ihr auch, warum?
1984 das beste
Geburtsdatum ist? Nicht, weil der erste
Mac released wurde 1984.
Nicht, dass das jetzt wirklich jemanden interessiert da
im Nachhinein.
Aber, nein.
Nein, deswegen auch nicht. 1984 oder, sag mal,
es kann auch 83, 84, 85, 86
oder so, ist egal. Also,
warum? Folgendermaßen.
Folgendermaßen. Also,
warum, warum ich denke, dass das beste,
beste Geburts, sag mal mal,
Jahrzehnt ist.
Du hast alles mitgekriegt.
Du hattest Pre-Computer.
Also, ich hatte ja, sag mal mal so, die ersten,
sag mal so, 10 Jahre meines
Lebens,
ja,
leicht nicht.
Ja, na doch. Na doch.
Sag mal so, die ersten 10 Jahre meines Lebens
hatte ich überhaupt nichts mit Computer
zu tun. Ich meine, gab es zwar damals
schon, aber das war überhaupt nicht verbreitet.
Damals hat auch keiner wirklich Computer daheim gehabt.
Später hatte dann vielleicht mal jemand mit
Amiga oder so, die Oldschool-Leute,
Atari oder sowas. Aber es war, war, war nichts, ne?
Also, sprich, ich hatte 10 Jahre
ganz klassisch,
ähm,
ganz klassisch so
Outdoor-Kindheit.
So. Kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen, ja?
Man ist dann, man ist dann an die Luft
und dann ist es in die Sonne und so.
Das kann man sich auch gar nicht vorstellen.
So. Und,
so, das hatte ich 10 Jahre.
Und danach hatte ich,
Bäm!
Internet, Computerstellz daheim.
Ich hab komplett,
also ich hab komplett Internetaufstieg,
Computer-Daheim-Aufstieg,
Gaming-Aufstieg und sonst was mitgekriegt.
Dazu kam,
dass das noch Pre-Smartphone war.
Ich hab auch noch Pre-Smartphone mitgekriegt.
Und ich war voll dabei, quasi jetzt auch noch
Post-Smartphone.
Also ich hab im Prinzip alle wichtigen
Entwicklungen durch mitbekommen.
Was richtig nice ist,
eigentlich. Und, und nix davon zu lang.
Es wär nämlich scheiße gewesen,
früher geboren zu sein, weil
dann bist du dann, dann wärst du dann schon so festgefahren.
Ja, 94, das ist
alles noch im Rahmen, ja? Aber da wärst du so,
stell dir mal vor, du wärst 74 geboren.
Dann, dann wär ich jemand gewesen,
der gesagt hätte, ähm,
der gesagt hätte, ah, komm,
Judo-Zeug, nee, nee, geh mal
mal weg, äh, da will ich
nix mit zu tun haben. Da hätt ich wahrscheinlich
wirklich das gemacht, was das Arbeitsamt gesagt hat.
Ich hätt was mit Holz gelernt.
Ja, also ich find, dass 1984
ist eigentlich das beste,
beste Geburtsjahr überhaupt.
Das Jahr des Linux-Desktops.
Ja, genau.
Ich dachte, 2022 wird
das Jahr des Linux-Desktops.
Soll ich euch sagen, wann realistisch gesehen
das Jahr des Linux-Desktops wird?
Nie.
Nie das Jahr des Linux-Desktops.
Außer, außer,
es kommt in einer ganz anderen Form,
als wir uns das denken.
Wenn jetzt zum Beispiel Chrome OS
oder sowas nochmal groß rauskommt,
oder Steam OS,
oder, ähm,
keine Ahnung,
Desktop Android,
dann vielleicht
in einer anderen Form, als wir uns das denken,
dann,
und ja, ich finde auch,
das Jahr des Linux-Desktops war im Prinzip schon
der beste, also der, der coolste
Linux-Desktop waren die Zeiten,
wo, äh,
Compets und Barrel und sowas
angesagt war mit, mit, äh,
mit solchen Dingern hier.
Ja?
Mit solchen Dingern.
Ja.
Wobbly Windows!
Und
warum auch immer die da jetzt,
das war, warum er da jetzt Markus Lanz anhat, aber okay.
Ja.
So.
Die, diese Views dann 3D, 3D-Desktop mit Würfel.
Ja.
Durchgeschalte.
Das gibt's heute teilweise immer noch, aber bei weitem nicht mehr so abgedreht.
Ja, die guten Funktionen, also die,
die seriösen Funktionen,
das ist auch so gut,
die seriösen Funktionen haben sie behalten,
aber, ähm,
so dieses ganze ultraverspielte und, und abgedrehte,
das haben sie ja meistens,
das hier, so Dinger da, ne, das war schon,
das war schon cool.
Oder die Fenster, die dann abgefackelt sind, wenn du sie geschlossen hast und sowas.
Keck W3D, ja.
Das war noch was, das fand ich richtig cool.
Das war für mich so die spannendste Zeit von Linux Desktop,
weil es, es einfach cool war und, und, sag mal,
Möglichkeiten, die andere Betriebssysteme gar nicht hatten.
Das konnte damals weder Windows noch Mac.
Ja gut, was anderes gibt's nicht.
Das war richtig cool.
Aber, sie haben da nie wirklich was, was draus gemacht.
Ich mein, gut, man muss ja sagen,
die Usability macht's jetzt nicht wirklich besser, ne.
Ich hatte damals auf der Arbeit übrigens einen Rechner,
wenn wir nur kurz, kurz husten.
So, schau dir mal Wayfire an.
Sagt mir gar nichts.
Aber da muss ich ja Wayland für verwenden.
Wayland Compositor, oh, das können wir uns vielleicht mal angucken irgendwann.
Da müssen wir mal gucken, ob das was taucht.
Äh, warte mal, Stream, Stream Ideen, hier, bam.
3D, 3D, 3D, 3D, 3D, 3D, 3D, 3D, 3D, 3D, 3D, 3D, 3D, 3D, 3D, 3D, 3D, 3D, 3D, 3D, 3D, 3D, 3D, 3D.
Zumindest, ich kann mich noch dran erinnern,
also ich hab ja damals meine Ausbildung angefangen und,
ich hatte damals, das ist, das ist übelst, übelster Schrott, ja.
Mir wurde damals, natürlich hab ich den Rechner auf der Arbeit bekommen,
der Desktop, das ist doch Poggers Desktop.
Ich find Instant auf alles, alles auf meinem Desktop.
So, ich hab, ich hab ja damals die Ausbildung angefangen,
also irgendwie vor, vor, vor 20 Jahren, ne,
2007 rum
Egal
Zumindest, die haben ja auf der Arbeit
Damals den Rechner gestellt und das war
Irgendein selbst zusammengebauter Rechner
Aus Einzelteilen von Alternate
Damals
Das war der schlechteste, billigste Rechner überhaupt
Das Ding hat quasi, wenn du es
Gerutscht hast auf dem Boden
Hat sich das Gehäuse gebogen
Ja, kennt ihr das, wenn die
Wenn ihr Sachen habt, wo die Platten
Wo die Platten zu
Zu dünn sind, also wenn das hier so euer Gehäuse
Von vorne ist, ja
Das ist euer Gehäuse von vorne
Und ich hab das Gehäuse verrutscht
Dann sah das Gehäuse so aus
So schlecht war das Gehäuse
Ich hab das verschoben, das Gehäuse vom Rechner
Dann sah das so aus danach
Zumindest, das ist meiner billigste
Kackrechner, den man überhaupt
Jemand zur Verfügung stellen konnte
Und
Damals weiß ich noch
Da war ich den ersten Tag da
Ich hatte nicht großartig Ahnung
Nicht Ahnung von Linux
Und da meinte einer zu mir so nach dem Motto
Hier, guck mal, hier hast du deinen Rechner
Installier dir mal einen Linux drauf
So, was hab ich damals gemacht
Das war da übrigens, der Rechner war für die damalige Zeit
Schon richtig kacke
Also, ich hab, einzige was ich großartig gekannt habe
Ich hab da Ubuntu Desktop drauf gemacht
Äh, natürlich gleich mal
Gleich mal Compits
Weil, ähm, das CPU gerendert
Auch alles so langweilig war, also
So, und dann ist mir irgendwann aufgefallen
Der Rechner kackt ab
Und dann hab ich den Rechner aufgemacht
Hab mal reingeguckt, hab festgestellt
Da war eine AMD Grafikkarte drin
Also erstens damals AMD Treiber
Und Treiber unter Linux, ganz ganz abenteuerliche Geschichte
Muss ich erstmal das Neueste installieren
Aber, was mir dann aufgefallen ist
Ich hab den Rechner aufgemacht, reingeguckt
Hab festgestellt, aha
Das ist ja eine Grafikkarte mit Lüfter
Aber ich hör gar keinen Lüfter
Und dann hab ich die Grafikkarte mir angeguckt
Und der Rechner war schon so alt und kaputt
Das war irgendwie verkrustet
Im Lüfter
Sprich, die haben mir den Rechner auf der Arbeit gestellt
Wer weiß wie alt das gewesen ist
Mit irgendwie verkrustetem CPU
Äh, äh, verkrustetem GPU Lüfter
Der sich nicht mal gedreht hat
Hab ich das Ding aufgeschraubt
Kann ich mich auch noch dran erinnern
Hab da ein bisschen dran rumgefuddelt an dem Lüfter
Das Problem ist nur, ich hab's dann schlimmer gemacht
Ich hab den Rechner dann eingeschaltet
Und der Lüfter ging wieder
Aber vorher war es so, dass ich dann
War Ruhe
Und nachdem ich eingeschaltet habe
Nachdem ich an dem Lüfter rumgespielt hab
Hat der Lüfter dann gemacht
Was natürlich schlecht war im Büro
Das ging dann erstmal allen auf den Sack
So
Na gut, wirklich kühler geblieben ist die Grafikkarte
Dann auch nicht davon
Und jetzt kommt, jetzt kommt Big Brain
Big Brain Hack
Das würde ich heute auch nicht mehr machen
Aber damals war das noch so die Zeit von
Man ist auch mit CDs ins Rechnen
Rechenzentrum und sowas
Das war, das war alles
Und jetzt durfte man alles nicht so eng nehmen
So, oder nicht so eng sehen
Und ich hab dann einfach den Grafikkartenlüfter
Komplett abgestöpselt
Ne, nicht Alu-Block
Das ist die der Bauer-Taktik, Alu-Block drauf
Ich hab dann, hatte ich ja auch nicht
Ich hab dann einfach
Ich hab dann einfach das Gehäuse aufgelassen
Ich hab den Grafikkartenlüfter ausgesteckt
Also ich hab den Strom rausgestöpselt
Was auch nicht so einfach war
Weil das Ding, ich weiß nicht
Ich hab den Strom rausgestöpselt
Das Kabel war einmal oder zweimal um die Grafikkarte drumrum gewickelt
Ich hab den Lüfter ausgestöpselt
Und ich hab das Gehäuse an der Seite aufgelassen
So, und das hat genau gereicht
Ein offenes Gehäuse
Ausgestöpselt im Grafikkartenlüfter
Dass das Ding bei irgendwie, was weiß ich
93 Grad oder so
Stable im Desktop-Betrieb gelaufen ist
Das war irgendein Celeron-CPU
Das war der beschissenste Arbeitsrechner aller Zeiten
Normalen Browser konnte ich da drauf auch nicht gescheit verwenden
Das war irgendwie so
Das war zu langsam
Hab ich damals Opera verwendet
Weil es das einzige lief
Also Azubi-Ausstattung war wirklich grausam damals
Aber ich hab's hingekriegt
Ja, und da hatte ich solche Dinge auf dem Desktop
Und seitdem war ich immer großer Fan von Wobbly Windows
Wobbly Windows ist einfach
In der Windows 10
Ne, da funktioniert die Hälfte dann nicht
Wie das geht?
Wobbly Windows unter Windows
Windows FX
Okay, man muss irgendeine komischen Crap-Purchasen
Purchasen
So, geht das?
Und dann Windows zeige ich mal her
Ja, ja
Wisst ihr, das sind immer die geilsten Videos
Erstmal ein Installer zusammenklicken zusammen
Das ist dann wahrscheinlich nicht mit irgendwelchen Games kompatibel oder so
Ja, Wobbly Windows
Exquisite
Aber halt unter Linux
Wobbly Windows
Jawohl, so muss das sein
So, und ich hab damals halt gedacht
Ich kann nie wieder einen Rechner verwenden
Ohne Wobbly Windows
Aber seitdem ich auf Tiling-Window mitgekommen bin
Wenn ich jetzt schon umgestiegen bin
Aber das ist auch schon
Keine Ahnung wie lange her
Ja, gibt's halt keine Wobbly Windows mehr
Weil es überhaupt keine Windows mehr
Weil es keine Windows mehr gibt in dem Fall
Oder sagen wir mal
Es gibt nur noch maximierte Windows
Also ihr hört's vielleicht
Ich hab irgendwas im Hals heute
Seit ein paar Tagen schon
Aber ich bin garantiert
In Frankfurt
Oder im Zug
Von und nach Frankfurt
Frankfurt-Kund
Warum sieht man hier eigentlich Füße?
Na zum Glück hat er jetzt nicht ein bisschen weiter hochgescrollt, Alter
Aber wir compilen Chrome
Alles klar
Ja Moment
Das da ist aber nicht Chrome-Compilen
Das ist Cat auf
Keine Ahnung
Dev-SDA oder sowas
Das ist kein Chrome-Compilen
So, YouTube, hast du noch mal eine Chance uns was Gutes vorzuschlagen
Cat auf
Gesamt-Linux-Curl
So sieht das ungefähr aus, wenn du Cat auf
Dev-SDA oder so machst
Ja, das hab ich auch gelesen
Bei den Dänen ist Corona jetzt vorbei
Dänen haben gesagt
Moment
Nein, das haben sie nicht gesagt
Die haben gesagt
Piss dich, Aldo
So, haben gesagt
Corona ist vorbei
Okay, also ihr seht heute mal
Die YouTube-Empfehlungen sind wirklich grausam wieder
Was ist denn das alles?
New Old Stock 17 Zoll CRT Monitor
Ah, das muss ich mir angucken
Oldschool, Oldschool-Shit
Einmal ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen
Ein bisschen vorspulen
Sekunde, warte mal
Chat, Chat gucken
Ich hab ein komplettes System-Backup mit Erste und Gute
Kann man machen, ja
Kann man machen
Ich mein, du kannst jetzt mit AirSync
So out of the box
Jetzt kein komplettes Plattendump
Inklusive Bootloader und sonst was ziehen
Aber die, die wichtigen Sachen backuppen kannst du
Mit, mit AirSync, ja
Äh, nö
Solltet ihr eigentlich
Zumindest mal die, die
Zeigt ihr das nicht, die aktuell zumindest geladenen Module an?
Keine Ahnung
Oder ne, das zeigt dir an, wo die liegen
Auf der, auf der Platte, ne
Ach, was weiß ich aus dem Kopf
Keine Ahnung
Ande, zwölf Monate
Hyper-Subscription hier
Huge
Meine Linux-Diskrepanzierung zerstört sich irgendwie immer selbst
Ich hab nix gemacht
Das, ja, das sagen sie alle
Vielleicht ist deine Platte im Arsch
Ich mein, wenn sie, wenn sich Sachen bei mir auf der, auf der
Wenn das, vor allem wenn das noch ne Magnetplatte ist
Immer von selbst zerstören
Dann würd ich mir mal gedacht, vielleicht ist meine Festplatte im Arsch
Ja, es geht mir auch so
Ich kann mir Wayland nicht geben
Das Problem ist, das Problem ist
Ich flame immer gern über Wayland, ne
Aber ich verwende das so selten
Dass meine Infos meistens schon outdated sind
Und ich die Hälfte schon wieder vergessen hab
Was mir eigentlich auf den Keks geht
Das letzte Mal weiß ich noch, konnte man, konnte man
Ähm
Anwendungen nicht richtig, äh
Größer, größer und kleiner machen
Dann hat er nämlich nicht
Das Fenster größer und kleiner gemacht
Sondern er hat die Anwendung komplett
In der Originalauflösung
Gelassen und hat die einfach nur hoch und runter skaliert
Ganz, ganz merkwürdig
Ich war damals schon Passivkühlungpionier
Ja, ich hab halt
Passiv gekühlt
Nehm ich die Lüfte rausgestöpselt hab
Was soll eigentlich der Vorteil von Wayland sein?
Der Vorteil von Wayland sollte mal
Oder ist noch, ich weiß ich gar nicht so genau
Sollte mal sein, dass es halt
Moderner, leichtgewichtiger und besser zu
Maintainen ist als X
Das mag auch so sein
Da kann ich, kann ich nix, nix so sagen
Ich mein, ich kann mir nur vorstellen, dass X wirklich
50 Jahre alter Schrott ist
Aber
Ähm, unter Linux
Verlassen sich so viele Dinge auf irgendwelche
Edge Cases, so Sachen die mal
Da waren und jetzt nicht mal da sind
Unter Wayland und sonst wie
Sodass im Prinzip Wayland wahrscheinlich
Mittlerweile
Komplexer wird als X
Weil sie noch Wayland plus alles alte von X
Unterstützen müssen
Aber ich bin da jetzt nicht im Bilde, was das, was das angeht
Pega
Dankeschön
Ich habe übrigens, ich habe übrigens gelesen
Das erzähle ich euch jetzt nicht, sonst
Die Leute wieder im Chat rum
Ande, 12 Monate
Hyper Subscription, Dankeschön, habe ich glaube ich schon
Vorgelesen, daher braucht man ja auch noch
X Wayland, ja wie gesagt, ich glaube
Mittlerweile haben die festgestellt
Dass wir machen einfach mal was Neues
Äh, schlankes Problem
Problematisch wird, wenn es die Hälfte nicht unterstützt, was die Leute
Haben wollen, so ich muss, ich muss mir
Jetzt mal kurz, wir gucken uns nicht
Das ganze Bild an
Ich will einfach nur ein bisschen
Äh, Oldschool Shit, jawoll
Akkusynk, ja die gab es damals
Akkusynk und Synkmaster
Synkmaster war glaube ich
Samsung, Synkmaster
Samsung Synkmaster
Wie, die gibt es
Heute noch
Das braucht doch keiner mehr
CRT, jawoll
Habe ich euch eigentlich schon
Erzählt, dass ich mich fast mal gekillt hätte
Mit einem Monitor
Und dann habe ich mich fast mal gekillt
Also in einem alternativen Universum
Bin ich heute gar nicht da
Damals ist mir
Ist mir mein Monitor abgeraucht
Und ich habe mir, also mein CRT
Was, was, was, why
Ja gut, wir wissen, wir wissen alle warum
Wir wissen alle warum
Mir ist damals mein Monitor abgeraucht
Sowas hier in der Richtung
21 Zoll, 21 Zoll
CRT Monitor
Und ich dachte mir damals, es ist eine gute Idee
Ich stöpsel den einfach ab und mache ihn auf
So, und ich habe den abgestöpselt
Zum Glück habe ich den abgestöpselt, ja
Abgestöpselt
Und direkt aufgemacht
Ohne nochmal einzuschalten oder sonst was
Dass komplett der ganze Strom weg ist
Also ich hätte mich da ohne Probleme
Schotten können
Ich war damals auch allein daheim
Mich hätte keiner gefunden
Ich wäre einfach RIP gewesen
Und ich habe den aufgeschraubt und komplett drin rumgefingert
Also
Hätte auch in die Hose gehen
Geleben am Limit, ja
Ja, das sind so
Dritte Welt
Linux User Probleme, ja
Ich habe übrigens auch einen schönen Bug
Mit meinem Laptop auf der Arbeit
Manchmal, ich weiß nicht genau warum
Ich vermute, wenn Leute irgendwie aus Versehen
Am Displayport wackeln
Oder was auch immer
Zumindest kommt das manchmal vor, dass mein Display nur mit 30 FPS läuft
Und Leute
Ich sag euch
Wenn ihr
Wenn ihr einen 240 Hertz Monitor
Gewohnt seid
Und könnt so ein Fenster bewegen
Und ihr seid dann auf der Arbeit
Und euer Bildschirm ist auf einmal
Wenn ihr morgens euch dran setzt
Auf 30 FPS
Dann wirkt das anstatt so
Wirkt das einfach nur
Das ist so laggy
Man muss dann einen ausstöpseln
Und dann geht das wieder
Ja, genau so
Ist das dann
So, äh, CRT Monitor
Akkusync, jawohl
Einfach im Homeoffice bleiben
Dann hat man das Problem nicht
Richtig, meine Rede
Was auch geil ist
Muss ich jetzt auch mal kurz loswerden
Ähm, bei mir in der Firma
Haben sie jetzt einen neuen Blogpost
Veröffentlicht
Ähm, wo sie auf die neue
Corona-Lage eingegangen sind
Also es ist ja so, dass gerade in Offenbach
Und Frankfurt sind die Inzidenzwerte
Wieder brutalst hoch
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, was heute Offenbach ist
Offenbach hat glaube ich 200
Aber sind jetzt auch schon alle auf den Trichter gekommen
Dass das als einzige Aussagegröße
Vielleicht auch nicht so sinnvoll ist
Äh
So, es ist zumindest hoch
Es fuck
Gut, die Seite geht nicht
Warum auch immer
Äh, tägliche Übersicht
Okay, es ist
Frank
Frankfurt
Alter
Offenbach 198
So
Zumindest
Äh, zumindest gab es jetzt einen neuen Blogpost
Bei mir auf der Arbeit
Offenbach ist Painschamp
Ja, Offenbach ist richtig
Offenbach ist so mit aus Painschamp
Wechsel, was du dir vorstellen kannst
Ja, Offenbach ist richtig
Zumindest gab es jetzt einen neuen Blogpost
Bei mir auf der Arbeit
Und das habe ich euch ja schon mal erzählt
Bei uns ist es immer so, wenn es einen Blogpost gibt
Da wird dann, keine Ahnung, von irgendeinem Vorstandstyp
Oder irgendeinem Managementtyp
Oder was auch immer, der die Rechte hat
Sind immer die gleichen paar
Wer einen Blogpost verfasst
Und es gibt immer die gleichen Handvoll Leute
Oder zwei Hände voll Leute
Die das immer liken
Egal welcher Blogpost das ist
Die liken das immer
So richtig Schleimermäßig
Blogpost like, like
Und die anderen Leute, die das immer liken
Haben glaube ich schon eine Notification drauf
Wenn es einen Blogpost gibt
Weil
Dass sie möglichst schnell liken können
Weil wenn du als einer der ersten likest
Steht dann nicht nur da
50 Leute haben das geliked
Sondern steht dann da
Max Woblors hat geliked
Ich glaube das bleibt dann sogar stehen
Für die ersten, die geliked haben
Das heißt, wenn man richtige Schleimattacke machen will
Muss man als erster immer
Ohne es vorher zu lesen, den Blogpost liken
Zumindest gab es jetzt
Einen Blogpost zur aktuellen Corona-Lage
Und das ist extrem widersprüchlich
Da steht sowas
Da steht sowas drinnen wie
Wir freuen uns
Dass unsere Corona-Maßnahmen
So effektiv sind
Und wir
Gehen jetzt ja auch langsam über
Wieder in den Normalbetrieb
Oder was auch immer sie da geschrieben haben
Und es freuen sich alle so
Dass sich endlich wieder alle im Büro
Auf Augenhöhe begegnen können
Also übelste Manager-Speak
Ich like nicht
So
Aber, also sie schreiben am Anfang
Quasi, okay Leute
Das ist jetzt die Begründung für
Warum wir wollen, dass ihr wieder ins Büro kommt
Und dann steht ein Satz unten drunter
Aber das wichtigste
Ist die Gesundheit unserer Mitarbeiter
Da habe ich mir gedacht
Wie schafft ihr das
Zwei Sätze hintereinander zu machen
Und euch so krass zu widersprechen
Erster Satz, jawoll Leute
Endlich alle wieder ins Büro
Und der zweite Satz ist
Ja, aber die Gesundheit ist uns das Wichtigste
Was zum
Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn
Mal ganz davon abgesehen
Mich betrifft es zum Glück eh nur zum Teil
Ich habe ja mein Arbeitszeitmodell geändert
Auf Homeoffice
Und ich bin jetzt
Dienstags bin ich immer in Frankfurt
Wahrscheinlich, planmäßig
Dienstags gehe ich jetzt immer nach Frankfurt
Gäbe mir da einen Tag Büro
Stell immer wieder fest
Wie wahnsinnig ineffektiv
Das ist
Wie das eigentlich ist
Und die restliche Woche
Gehe ich dann heim und mache dann auch was
Weil an dem Tag wo ich im Büro bin
Mache ich nichts
Das ist nicht weil ich nichts machen will
Sondern weil es im Büro einfach nicht richtig funktioniert
Das ist ein Großraumbüro
Ich sitze ja da wo auch unser Support sitzt
Das heißt er wird öfters mal ein bisschen telefoniert
Was ich dann wirklich wild finde
Aber ich nerv die anderen
Wenn ich telefoniere weil ich irgendwelche Teammeetings habe
Dann hast du manchmal einen der ein bisschen lauter telefoniert
Dann hast du irgendeinen der dir was erzählt
Dann willst du einmal kurz nur was fragen
Der erzählt dir eine halbe Stunde was neues passiert ist
Du kannst im Büro
Ich weiß gar nicht wie ich das früher gemacht habe
Du kannst im Büro einfach nicht richtig arbeiten
Das funktioniert nicht
Im Vergleich zu daheim
Kennst du Leute die so mega laut telefonieren
Klar
Ich muss aber sagen
Ich glaube ich telefoniere auch manchmal relativ laut
Weil ich habe meinen Kopfhörer auf
Und ich mache das Noise Cancelling schon immer aus
Aber ich habe meinen Kopfhörer auf
Hab halt dann Freisprechdings an
Und rede halt normal
Und ich glaube
Dass das wahrscheinlich auch in dem Büro
Wo nicht viele Leute drin sind gerade
Aber halt genug
Sodass man sich nervt
Dass das andere teilweise schon nervt
Wenn ich Teamsmeeting mache
Außerdem du erwischst viel Leute
Viel einfacher
Wenn sie daheim sind
Wenn jemand daheim ist und ich muss kurz was wissen
Gehe ich ins Teams gucke ob der anwesend ist
Oder ob der in den letzten 5 Minuten anwesend war
Oder irgendeinen Status hat
Gehe ins Teams rein und sage hier kannst du kurz gucken
Fertig dann meldet er sich meistens
Vor Ort
Schreibst ihn an
Er meldet sich nicht
Du gehst rüber zum Platz
Guckst wo er ist
Er ist nicht da
Und die sagen
Ah ich glaube der mietet gerade irgendwo
Ja bis wann
Ja keine Ahnung
Das ist einfach für alle Beteiligten viel besser
Wenn die Leute daheim sind
Vor allem in der Kombination
Wenn die Leute was machen daheim
Ich bin aber trotzdem der Meinung
Ich habe übrigens auch eine mechanische Tastatur auf der Arbeit
Ja ja ich kenne das
Ich kenne das
Ich habe auch eine mechanische Tastatur
Aber ich habe Silikonringe
Unter den wichtigsten Tasten die ich haue
Ich habe ja so den Hang dazu
Die
Enter-Taste beispielsweise
Von meinem Num-Block
So zu hauen
Und das geht natürlich den Leuten auf den Sack
Deswegen habe ich da einen Silikonring drunter
Und dann ist das nicht so schlimm
Ja aber ich bin der Meinung man sollte einfach
Das den Leuten anbieten
Und wer wirklich ins Büro kommen will
Kann das ja machen
Da habe ich ja überhaupt nichts dagegen
Wir haben zum Beispiel einen der weiß nicht
Also das hat er mir erzählt
Dass das ihn seine Kinder und Frau daheim so nervt
Der geht lieber ins Büro
Okay kann ich irgendwie nachvollziehen
Wobei ich es halt nicht so gut verstehe
Bei manchen Leuten ja
Die dann in der Küche sitzen
Und meinen dort gescheit Home-Office machen zu können
Da rennen die Leute um dich drum herum
Du hast keine gescheiten Armlehnen und nichts
Wie kommt man auf die Idee
Dass man auf einem Sofa auf einem Stuhl in der Küche
Oder sonst wo ordentlich Home-Office machen kann
Das heißt nicht umsonst Office
Du brauchst einen Arbeitsplatz
Du brauchst einen ordentlichen Stuhl
Du brauchst einen ordentlichen Schreibtisch
Du brauchst einen ordentlichen Rechner
Du brauchst einen ordentlichen Monitor
Du brauchst ordentliches Equipment
Das Headset darf sich nicht so anhören
Dann hast du es gerade im Arsch stecken
Ähm
Du brauchst ordentliches Equipment
Und die Leute die am meisten über Home-Office meckern
Ach das ist doch alles nichts
Das sind die Leute
Die das unter den unergonomischsten Bedingungen daheim machen
Ja
Aber es soll jeder machen wie er will
Ich hab da wirklich kein Problem
Weil Leute sagen sie wollen ins Büro gehen
Sollen sie das machen
Das ist in Ordnung
Was ich doof finde ist
Wenn da irgendwelche ähm
Etwas älteren ähm Manager Generationen
Der Meinung sind sie wüssten jetzt
Was das Beste ist
Was das Beste ist für alle Leute
Sie wissen ja noch nicht mal
Was das Beste für die Firma ist
Das äh
Ist tatsächlich der Wahnsinn
Was bei uns teilweise für Entscheidungen getroffen werden
Da greif ich mir echt an den Kopf
Man hat das auch oft genug gesehen
Dass es in die Hose geht
Also ich weiß nicht
Ob es bei uns eine
Äh wie nennt man das
Wie nennt man sowas richtig
Performance-Analyse glaub ich heißt das
Von Managerarbeit gibt
Kann ich mir aber nicht vorstellen
Was da tatsächlich ist?
Was da teilweise entschieden wird
Und was da teilweise für Geld
Durch die Lappen geht
Weil irgendwelche
Also das ist echt der Wahnsinn
Ich sag nicht dass ich das prinzipiell besser könnte
Das will ich gar nicht sagen
Aber manche Dinge sind so
Offensichtlicher Schwachsinn
Und sind auch schon oft genug nach hinten losgegangen
Wo ich mich immer frage
Wie schaffen die das eigentlich sich das so krass schön zu reden
Immer
Naja egal
Ähm
Achja das ist auch so ein Ding
Es gibt
Es gibt viele
Es gibt viele Berufe und so
Da geht das vielleicht nicht so richtig
Aber
Ich bin da an sich
Gerade was das Thema Homeoffice angeht
Es gibt viele Berufe
Da geht es
Wenn beide
Beide Seiten wollen
Ja
Also zum Beispiel
Wenn man jetzt als Handwerker arbeitet
Klar
Wenn du jetzt vor Ort irgendwo hinfahren musst
Und da
Irgendeine Wand
Äh verputzen
Oder
Einen Zaun bauen
Oder keine Ahnung
Dann kannst du das natürlich nicht von daheim aus machen
Aber wenn du irgendwelche
Ähm
Rechnungsgeschichten machen musst
Fortbildungssachen
Äh
Was auch immer
Ja
Ich bin kein Handwerker
Ich weiß es nicht genau
Gibt bestimmt die Möglichkeit
Wenn man das ordentlich organisiert
Die Leute das selbst wollen
Und der Chef das will
Dass die auch den ein oder anderen Tag Homeoffice machen könnten
Bin ich mir sicher
Dass das funktioniert
Wenn alle wollen
Äh
Du würdest gerne mein Zimmer als Homeoffice einlassen
Naja
Wahrscheinlich hast du ja schon alles
Du brauchst einen ordentlichen Monitor
Du brauchst einen ordentlichen Rechner
Du brauchst einen ordentlichen Schreibtisch
Tastatur
Stuhl
Also im Prinzip alles das
Was die Leute eh schon haben
Die relativ viel online machen
Ja
Man sollte es vielleicht nicht
Auf dem Klo
Oder in der Küche
Oder im Wohnzimmer
Auf dem Sofa machen
Weil äh
Da kann man nicht gescheit arbeiten
Du brauchst eine Tür
Die du zumachen kannst
Am besten eine Tür
Auch die du abschließen kannst
Wenn du nervige Leute hast
Das war's
Gescheites Headset
Ansonsten brauchst du ja nichts
Übrigens
Ich hab's jetzt auf der Arbeit
Überredet soweit
Endlich
Hab ich's geschafft
Äh
Ich krieg jetzt
Eine jährliche
Jetbrains
Rider
License
Aktuell verwende ich meine private
Ich hab jetzt lang genug erzählt
Was ja auch so ist
Dass ich halt nicht gescheit arbeiten kann
Ohne IDE
Und
Wir haben das jetzt endlich beantragt
Dass ich
Weil das ist ja nicht so
Dass das teuer wär
139 Euro
Was
Was juckt das denn
Ja
Endlich
Krieg ich jetzt eine ordentliche Lizenz
Kann ich auf der Arbeit auch gescheit
.NET
Programme
Programmieren machen
Dann verwende ich meine private
Lizenz
Aber
Ja
Die meisten
Also die ganzen
Java Hackermans
Bei uns verwenden
IntelliJ
Aber IntelliJ
Kost nix
Rider kost was
IntelliJ
Ist also quasi
Das
Angebot von Jetbrains
Um dir zu zeigen
Wie cool Jetbrains ist
Ich glaub
Peitscham
Ist auch kostenlos
Oder
Ist Peitscham
Nicht auch kostenlos
Ruby
Mein
Gibt's das immer noch
Ja
Genau
Also Peitscham Community
Ist kostenlos
Und ich glaub
IntelliJ
Ist auch kostenlos
Aber der Rest kost was
Boah
Egal
So
Witt
Jawoll
Akku Sync
Wie gesagt
Ich hab immer Sync Master
Also wenn ich den Arm von ihm sehe
Ich weiß nicht wie er ausschaut
Aber
Wenn ich den Arm von ihm sehe
Ich würde
Ich würde vermuten
Dass der auch
Ein bisschen
Äh
Pipo Fett ist
Das
Der sieht wahrscheinlich
Umgeformt
Das sieht ein bisschen aus
Wie mein Arm
Wie sieht's bei dir mit VR-Brillen aus
Hab ich nix
Weil
Ich hab
Ich hab nix
Weil
Es gibt nix
Was ich mit VR-Brillen machen will
Außer Half-Life spielen
Und nur für Half-Life
Finde ich
Lohnt sich das überhaupt nicht
Warum soll ich 500 Euro ausgeben
Für irgendwie
Dann
Oder
Noch mehr
Weil
Oder noch mehr
Für nen Setup
Ähm
Ja
Um dann ein Spiel zu spielen
Ne
VR-Porn
Zwar
Ich wusste es
Dass jetzt irgendeiner
Mit VR-Porn
Um die Ecke kommt
Wir skippen mal ein bisschen vor
Jawoll
Warte mal
Zack
Ah zu weit
Hier Refresh Rate
Guck mal 120 Hertz
Heute
Werden
Mit 120 Hertz
Ein super krasses
Gaming Equipment
Verkauft
Damals war das normal
CRTs 120 Hertz
Vielleicht nicht auf
1600x1200
Ne was war das für ne Auflösung
Glaube ich
Oder
4 zu 3 Resolutions
Kurz gucken
Videobrock
List of Common Resolutions
Hier
Zeig mal
Aha
Was hat man hier
Wow
Alter Wikipedia
Ist wieder zu
Zu
Zu Five Head
Für mich
1600x1200
Ja
Aber da steht nicht
Was 4 zu 3 ist
Das ist mir zu
Five Head
Das Ding
Also
Ja
1600x1200
War das
Glaube ich
Ja
4 zu 3
Genau
Ja
UXGA
Heißt das
Das war mir
So nicht bewusst
Dass ich
Damals in
UXGA
Gespielt hab
Das schwarz
War doch auch echt
Naja
Das schwarz
Bei einem CRT
War insofern
Echt
Weil einfach
Kein Licht
Da war
Und dementsprechend
War der Pixel
Halt aus
CRT
Hattest du ja
Im Endeffekt
Vorne
Oder mal nicht
Guck mal
Ob man das hier sieht
Du hast ja
Bei einem CRT
Du hast ja vorne
Hier relativ
Großer Glaskörper
Dahinter
Hast du so
Eine Schicht aus
Ist das irgendwie
Irgendwas
Phosphor
Oder so
Keine Ahnung
Mit Elektronen
Und
Dementsprechend
Haben die
Ich weiß nicht
Mal genau
Wie der Kram
Funktioniert hat
Ähm
Zumindest
Das wird
Diese
Diese Phosphor
Schicht
Wird hier
Von hinten
Angeschossen
Dann leuchtet
Der Pixel
Erleuchtet
Aber nur
Ganz kurz
Deswegen
Muss der Strahl
Halt hier
Rumwandern
Und das
Immer wieder
Ja
Du hast
Ein Elektronenstrahl
Der saust
Hier wie verrückt
Über alle Zeilen
Des Monitors
Drüber
Von links oben
Nach rechts unten
Und dann fängt er wieder
Oben an
Daher kommt übrigens
Auch der Name
Wie Sync
Beziehungsweise
Refresh
Raid
Weil das wirklich
Die Rat ist
In der das hier
Gebraucht hat
Von einmal
Oben links
Nach einmal
Unten rechts
Und wieder von oben
Nach oben links
Und dann fängt er
Wieder an
Daher
Refresh
In dem sinne
Wie es heute bei
Tft
Monitoren
Und so was
Gibt
Ich habe
Ganz was Anderes
Als das
Wie es
Hier mehr
Zerratet
Wurde
Er wirklich
Du musst das
Bild
Refreshen
Sonst
Hättest du
Gar kein Bild
Gesehen
Dementsprechend
Wahrheit
Auch schwarz-schwarz
Bild muss mein CRT theoretisch
nix machen. Äh, mein
Schwachsinn, mein TFT. Nix machen.
So, für das Standbild müsste es nix machen.
Ein CRT müsste die ganze Zeit das Bild
refreshen. Das ist das, was ich sehe.
Oh, das ist
aber richtig oldschool.
Kennt noch jemand, wenn man einen Monitor degaust
hat? Das kennen nur
oldschool Leute. Wissen, wie man
Monitore degaust.
Ah, jawoll.
Schöner VGA.
Degaust habe ich, glaube ich, schon mal
gezeigt, aber ich finde es immer
CRT degaust.
Passt mal auf hier. Jetzt wird degaust.
Wo macht der das?
Alter.
Was macht der denn da?
Jawoll, das da. Das da meine ich.
Das da meine ich.
Ja, weil das Ding
von magnetischen Einflüssen, hast du
vielleicht kennt das noch jemand?
Wenn jemand mal
Lautsprecher neben
seinem Monitor stehen hatte.
Bisschen größere Lautsprecher. Da sind ja
Magnete drin.
In Lautsprechern.
Und dann hat man sich gewundert, warum der Monitor
teilweise so
Kreise auf der Seite hatte.
Das lag daran, weil
die Magnete in dem Lautsprecher
den Strahl
hier vom CRT abgelenkt haben.
Manchmal
ist das hängen geblieben
und du musstest das dann weit genug
weg machen und einmal
degausen.
Ja gut, was auch immer.
Degaust.
Max, hast du früher Text-Only-Monitore
erlebt?
Du meinst Text-Only-Betriebssysteme
von den Monitoren.
Was der Monitor anzeigt, ist dem egal.
Oder meinst du noch so Oldschool
Text-Interface-Überdrucker?
Jawoll.
Das Ding wiegt wahrscheinlich 20 Kilo
oder so.
Viel zu neu. Das ist schon Pentium 3, Alter.
Das hier.
Oh hier, wichtigste, das wichtigste
Tool damals.
Demon Tools.
Da konnte man Isos
mounten unter Windows.
Demon Tools, Leute, ich sag's euch.
Natürlich, natürlich,
natürlich nur rein für
rein für legale Zwecke
verwendet, Demon Tools.
Ich will
Unreal Tournament spielen.
Jawoll.
Alter, hör mal auf, Solitaire.
Was ist das?
Irgendwie Sim Tower
oder irgendwie sowas?
Wie gesagt, September 11-12
2020.
Ja, nice.
So, YouTube, letzte Chance
gescheite Videos vorzuschlagen.
Nope. Hat keinen Bock.
Clone CD war auch...
Also...
Ich kann mich nur noch an Demon Tools
erinnern.
Demon Tools Lite war das.
Genau. Das hatten wir
für Windows damals. Für Isos.
Und
dann gab es noch...
Wie hieß das Ding zum CD
brennen? Nero
oder so gab's da noch.
Weil das Problem war, wenn du damals CDs
gebrannt hast, wenn du die CD...
Also du konntest
die CD nicht abbrechen. Das Ding war nicht...
Das Ding war nicht... war nicht
advanced genug.
Ja, das mit der Flamme, genau.
So.
Zumindest, wenn du damals eine CD gebrannt hast,
bei den alten Laufwerken und bei den
Kackrechnern und bei Windows 8, Leute, so...
Du konntest das nicht wieder...
Du konntest das nicht wieder aufnehmen.
Das heißt, du musstest den Rechner anmachen, musstest
sagen, hey, brenn jetzt was. Und du hast
im Prinzip immer die Hand
hochnehmen müssen, so nach dem Motto,
ich mach jetzt nix, dass es nicht abgekackt ist.
So, und dann gab's dann teilweise Software,
die hat angefangen, das quasi zu buffern.
Dass das...
Dass du nicht so leicht
deinen Brennvorgang schrotten konntest.
Und später hat's dann
Laufwerke, die das konnten.
Da gab's dann irgendwann sogar CD-RW
und solche abgedrehten Dinger.
Ultra ISO,
das kenn ich nicht mehr. Wie gesagt, ich kann mich nur an
Demon Tools erinnern.
Was ist das? Alter!
Was... 33 Pfund.
Was sind denn das?
Pound. Vor allem, welche Pound
tu Kilogramm?
15.
Ja, die Hälfte ungefähr. 15.
15 Kilogramm, Katze!
Alter! Meine wiegt,
glaub ich, 5 Kilo oder so. Und die ist
auch jetzt nicht die aller... Also Chico
ist jetzt auch nicht die Allerdünnste, ja?
Die wiegt, glaub ich, irgendwie 5 Kilo.
Aber... Alter!
Chonker, äh...
Richtig huge, huge
Chonker.
Ja. Alter, ist die fett!
Boah!
Was? Warum baden
Leute ihre Katze? Kann mir das mal irgendjemand
erklären? Das ist total unsinnig,
die Katze zu baden. Okay, vielleicht
den Dicken, weil der nicht mal überall hinkommt.
Aber...
Man muss seine Katze nicht baden.
Um die sauber zu machen, Katzen machen sich selbst
sauber. Du musst die Katze nicht baden.
Jawoll.
Oh, das sind die Chinamäuse, die
hab ich auch. Ja, er ist
wirklich viel dünner. Guck mal hier!
Das ist ja kaum noch dieselbe Katze.
Also meine Katze,
die erste hier, die ich hatte, die Original-Katz-FPS,
die war quasi
fast nur draußen.
Und ich musste die nicht einmal
baden. Wozu?
Der einzige, also das einzige,
was mir einfallen würde ist, wie gesagt,
in dem Fall, wenn die Katze vielleicht so fett ist, dass sie es selbst nicht mehr
machen könnte, oder
dass die in irgendwas Klebriges reingefallen
ist oder so, was sie halt sonst
nicht abbekommt.
Aber, oder in Farbe
oder in irgendwas, keine Ahnung.
Aber, das passiert ja selten.
Okay, aber normalerweise musst du das nicht machen.
Ja.
Alter, was ein
Figgersack!
Aber jetzt,
aber jetzt, guck mal hier!
Ja. Okay, Flöhe
und Krankheiten. Ja, okay, das ergibt Sinn.
Das vielleicht auch noch. Aber normalerweise musst du deine Katze
nicht baden.
Aber, ja, die machen das schon.
Die sind ja nicht umsonst
einen halben Tag damit beschäftigt,
sich so
abzulecken.
Okay, was gucken wir uns jetzt an?
Hacking Nintendo Wii,
Jit Commands,
Old Servers, Battlefield 3,
Ach komm, wir gucken uns ne Runde.
Wir gucken uns ne Runde
Battlefield 3 Leute an, die
nicht die zwei linke Hände beim Spielen haben.
Moment, ist das, ist das ne
Mit Code oder Visier
Das ist auch mal was abgedreht
Na gut, warum nicht
Leider ist Venice dead
Die haben es halt ein bisschen verkackt
Alter, die lassen sich aber wieder bashen
Wisst ihr, was das Gute an Battlefield 3 ist?
Dass Battlefield 3 nur noch PC-Clips sind
Niemand spielt mehr Battlefield 3 auf der Konsole
Das heißt, wenn du Clips siehst
Sind die im Prinzip immer zu 99% vom PC
Und dementsprechend haben sie gescheite Quali
BF4 sieht anders aus
Richtige PP-Gas, Alter
Massive PP-Ga-Gegner
Ah, er wieder
Man kann nicht mal sein Venice-Account löschen
Gut, das würde mich jetzt nicht so interessieren
Dass man das löschen kann
Aber es gibt halt keine Server
Komm, wir gucken mal kurz
Lass mal gucken
Azubi 2.2 MP4
Ah
Das ist das Video
So, hab ich mal Probe gezeigt
Kann man löschen
So, mal gucken
Wir können mal raten
Wie viel der vollste Server hat
Ich tipp mal auf drei Leute
Wobei, es ist Sonntagmorgen
Es ist Sonntagmorgen
Vielleicht sind es auch sechs Leute
Einer, einer
Einer, nice
Richtig, Poggers
Ah, wieder mit seinem Smoke-Launcher
Jetzt wird wieder rumgesprayt, jawoll
Bam, bam, bam
Rex, Beste, Alter
Mich würde mal interessieren, wie viele Stunden er hat
Er hat bestimmt auch schon 6000 Stunden Battlefield 3 oder so
Wow
Dass er den getroffen hat, hätte ich nicht gedacht
Oh, wie ist es nicht checken, Alter?
Wie ist es nicht checken?
Ah, Mist, Mist!
Das hätte ein nice Clip geben können, nochmal
Also, auch viel besser
Warum ich glaube, warum Venice gefloppt ist
Mehrere Gründe
Erstens
Ja, nicht
Es hatte zwar ein bisschen Aufmerksamkeit generiert
Aber nicht genug
Also, auch ein bisschen Marketing-Technik nicht so gut gemacht
Man hätte bestimmt auch mehr
Große Streamer nicht drauf setzen müssen
Dass sie das schon machen, sondern auch mal aktiv anschreiben
Also, Streamer und YouTube-Leute
Und so, irgendwie da mal aktiv
Den Kontakt suchen und
Das Wichtigste, wovon ich von ausgehe
Das ist der größte Punkt, warum Venice gescheitert ist
Es gab keine offiziellen Server
Du hättest offizielle Server haben müssen
Die auf einer Version sind, die funktioniert
Noch viel wichtiger
Die gescheit administriert, moderiert sind
Und die nicht zu weit weg sind
Vom originalen Battlefield 3
Aber die Vorzüge von Venice zeigen
Zum Beispiel, man könnte bei...
Man hätte einen offiziellen Rush
Und einen offiziellen Conquest-Server machen können
Und darauf hätte man zum Beispiel
Die Mods für den Blaufilter drauf machen können
Man hätte Mods drauf machen können
Dass Engineer-Waffen von Medics verwendet werden können
So leichte Anpassungen
Die das Game irgendwie neu und frisch machen
Man hätte ein cooles Progression-System machen können
Und all solche Dinger
Aber das steht und fällt halt mit offiziellem Support
Und offiziellen Servern
Was es halt nicht gegeben hat
Du hattest nichts, was du gescheit spielen konntest
Du hattest irgendwelche Server, wo der Admin-Service nicht da war
Du hattest irgendwelche Server, wo der Admin selbst gehackt hat
Das will ja keiner drauf spielen
Matrix HD, danke für den Sub
13 auch hier, 15 Monate
Ne, 23 Monate, huge Hyper-Subscription
Ja, und die letzten
Des letzten Rest an Spiele haben sie sich gekillt
Weil sie einen Memory-Leak hatten
Dass du nach zwei Runden gecrashed bist
Oder nach zwei Minuten oder was auch immer
Weiß nicht, ob sie das je wieder gefixt haben
Aber, RIP
Ja, nicht nur Cheating-Admins
Cheatende Server-Besitzer
Das ist ja auch so
Das kann ja nicht sein
In der S gesniped kriegen sie
Und so checken sie nicht
Oh, der war nice
Der war nice, dass er den noch erwischt hat
Dank Suppression auch Glück gehabt, dass das funktioniert hat
Battlefield 3 Suppression
Wissen wir noch
Collateral X
Nice, nice
Okay, der zweite war schon sehr, sehr glücklich
Alter, die Schneiber-Action, ne?
Ist das, ist das 360?
Das ist Xbox-Gameplay, oder?
Das sieht so kantig aus
Das ist bestimmt Xbox-Gameplay
Ne, Moment, da oben
Das ist PC
Da ist ansonsten keine Frame-Anzeige
Das ist die Debug-Frame-Anzeige
Das ist PC
Aber was zum Teufel ist das für ein PC?
Sieht aus wie Xbox 360
Wahrscheinlich ist es ein PC aus der Ära
Also
Das ist ein sehr guter
Der ist ein sehr guter
Logitech
Ja gut
Katz bildet es hier immer
Welches Headset ich empfehle für das Homeoffice?
Das ist egal
Irgendwas mit gescheiter
Mikrofon-Qualität
Das geht alles mögliche
Ich habe immer mein MMX300 auf
Das gleiche wie jetzt auch
Naja komm, also so geil ist der Clip jetzt nicht
Moment, vielleicht kommt jetzt ja noch was
Ah, das ist nice
Das fühlt sich voll an wie Konsolengameplay
Aber es ist kein Konsolengameplay
Das ist kein Konsolengameplay
Das war schon ein paar nice Shots jetzt
Auf der Arbeit habe ich dieses Wireless Headset
Wo ich festgestellt habe
Dass das sogar ein Mikrofon hat
Aber hier daheim verwende ich mein
MMX300
Ja das kannst du auch machen
Du kannst auch ein separates Mikro und Kopfhörer holen
Das ist ja das was ich auch immer
Empfohlen habe in der Vergangenheit
Aber wenn man unbedingt eine Headset Kombi haben will
Sag mal so, das MMX300 ist wunderbar
Es kostet halt was
Also wenn du preis-leistungsmäßig was haben willst
Was qualitativ besser ist als jedes Headset
Wobei man es da mittlerweile durchaus paar brauchbare gibt
Dann hol dir ein Mikrofon und Kopfhörer
Allerdings kann ich es aufgrund der Handhabung nachvollziehen
Wenn man sagt, man möchte ein Headset haben
Weil selbst wenn man sich so was
Kopfhörer mit irgendeinem Mod-Mic holt
Die aktuellen Mod-Mics sind ja auch nicht billig
Wie machst du das im Home-Office mit der Hardware?
Sag ich gleich was zu
Was hat der für ein Lack?
Der hat die Scheibe gemessert und das hat 3 Sekunden gedauert
1,94 in your face
Warum spielen die alle in so ultra niedriger Auflösung?
Ist das irgendwie
Muss man das als Battlefield Pro machen?
Irgendwie in 1280x720 spielen?
Oder ist das irgendwie so?
Oder ist das einfach nur weil die Rechner so kacke sind?
Durchs Redboxen
Genau
Das wie in CS
Großes Ril boxen 4 zu 3
Würde sich da einfach mal einer umdrehen von den Typen
Würde sich da einfach mal eine umdrehen von den Typen
Genau
feelsmedia.de
Yeah
das ist was was mich die battlefield 3 immer richtig genervt hat wenn es
wiederbeleben nicht funktioniert im battlefield 3 backt das wiederbeleben ja
teilweise rum wenn medikits davor steht oder aber wenn die irgendwie halb
hinter was liegen oder sonst wie da war mir das bad company 2 wiederbeleben
fast besser da konnte ich die wand wiederbeleben alles was in der nähe war
kannst du wiederbeleben alter was mit euch los die stehen immer noch da die
stehen immer noch da warum es wird ständig auf die pistole
was ist mit euch los ist das ist das haben die das gefällt oder was das
kannst du das so was sowas hast du doch normalerweise nicht metro in 20 42
confirm nicht
glaub nicht
ich bin nicht da
aber aber nose hair candles ist confirmed in 20 42
dann holst du es dir nicht
ja ne wer möchte nicht wer möchte nicht metro 64 vs 64 metro b flagge haben
24 7 5000 tickets rote dreiecke ja das ist halt das problem an smoke in battlefield 3
ja ich finde also gegen gute defender ist metro wirklich schwierig alle alle
punkte eigentlich die sind alle so blind aber m 4 16 beste beste waffe hier habe
ich glaube ich die meisten spielstunden mit macht ein schmicksack was ich mich
da gerade drauf kommen
hat er wieder was was neues ich weiß ja dass der typ bevor mich jetzt wieder
irgendeiner aufklärt und sagte max aber eigentlich heißt ich weiß dass das
eigentlich glaube ich ein britischer comedy mann ist und dass das ja einfach
quasi als verarschung gedacht war diese ganze big schack geschichte als man
trotzdem irgendwie mal was anderes fand dass ich fand das lustig
quick maps also 20 42 gibt es gibt es noch wieder immer gespannt wann denn
dieses event ist ich darf nicht an wie gesagt ich habe zwar nichts nix genaues
erzählen aber es gibt noch
es gibt noch
es gibt wohl noch mal einen noch mal die möglichkeit für gewisse content
creators im vorfeld das spiel anzuspielen und ich hoffe mal ich
erfahre bald wann das ist wie trotz ich sag gleich was zu der home office frage
wenn das fertig ist ist ja gleich durch ja gut weil es noch scharen gun clip
so also hier home office wollte ich was zu sagen also und zwar
da bin ich ja neugierig dass ich etwas wo den Fantasy
dieser
kanale
ich schίζet
ja
wir stellen uns einmal Fragen können oder nicht
ok
äh, Noisegate, dass es sich
ausschaltet, wenn ich, äh,
nix sag. Ein bisschen
noch den Gain geboostet und, und
Kompressorsettings, die ich irgendwo aus dem Internet hab.
So, easy, fertig.
So, warte mal, wo war das denn? Hardware. Also, ja,
genau, also, wie machst du das mit,
äh, wie machst du das
im Homeoffice mit der Hardware? Du hast
ein Notebook von der Arbeit, ein Dockingstation mit
KVM. Ne, also,
bei uns ist es relativ, zum Glück,
äh,
äh, relativ einfach. Und zwar,
ähm,
ich setz mich morgens an den gleichen Rechner, wo
ich jetzt hier auch bin. Ich hab mir nur den eigenen
Windows-Account gemacht für, für Homeoffice.
Ich will ja nicht den
Recording-Ordner aus Versehen mal leaken,
in einem Teams-Meeting.
Ne, ähm, ich hab meinen eigenen Account
gemacht und ich sitz am gleichen Rechner.
Ich hab links nen Monitor, rechts nen Monitor
und
wir haben zwei Möglichkeiten, wie man sich verbinden kann.
Man kann sich entweder
über, äh, nen Browser
verbinden, da gibt es so nen, so nen Remote
Windows Remote-Portal, was aber ziemlich
suckt, weil es laggy as fuck ist.
Oder es gibt die Möglichkeit über
VPN. Wobei die Möglichkeit
über VPN jetzt
äh, mittlerweile relativ stark
beschnitten ist und, äh,
daraufhin ich jetzt an einigen Stellen rumgemeckert
hab, dass ich nicht mehr arbeiten kann.
Mal gucken, was, was da rauskommt.
Ja, und für meine Broggers-Geschichten
hab ich ne, hab ich ne Ubuntu-VM.
Wo ich mich dann für
verbinde. Aus der hab ich dann auch immer VPN
gemacht.
VPN auf Privat, warum nicht?
Was ist der Unterschied?
Also, gibt es wirklich irgendjemand,
der glaubt, dass, äh,
Leute mit Root-Zugängen
in irgendeiner Art und Weise auf
ihren privaten Rechner schlechter aufpassen
können als auf den, auf das Firmen-Notebook?
Oder dass das die Firmen-Admins
irgendwie besser können als, äh,
als die Leute selbst?
Das halte ich für ein Gerücht.
Ich seh da überhaupt kein Problem.
Ja, auch überall auf der Welt
Bring-Your-Own-Device immer aktueller
wird.
Ja, weil, die glauben, ey, es gibt sicherlich
Leute, da ist das so.
Es gibt sicherlich, es gibt sicherlich Leute,
da ist das wirklich so, ja, die können das nicht.
Aber ich hab da keine, keine Schmerzen mit.
Ich komm ja mit meinem VPN-Zugang
auch nirgendwo hin.
Na, also, wenn ich mit meinem VPN-Zugang
wirklich auf irgendwelche Produktivsysteme
will, da muss ich mich, lass mal
überlegen, was muss, was, was, was, was muss ich denn machen?
Ja, ich brauch VPN,
Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung.
Ich brauch Login, Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung.
Ich brauch, ähm,
ja, wie soll man
das nennen, ähm,
Admin, Admin-Zugang
zwischen, zwischenstellt,
Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung. Also, man kann's,
ich muss, ich brauch zweimal,
ich brauch dreimal Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung,
dass ich überhaupt irgendwo drauf
bin, dass ich auch nur dran denken kann,
mich auf ein produktives System zu verbinden.
Also, dass das
irgendeiner hijackt, da hab ich so meine
Zweifel. Genau, sag ich, sag ich,
es kommt auf die Leute an, ne, du hast sicherlich Leute,
die können das nicht, da würde ich dann auch
äh, sagen, hey, benutzt mal schön den Laptop.
Ich hätte übrigens auch gar
keine Schmerzen mit, wenn die mir den Notebook
geben würden. Ich würde sogar den Windows-Notebook
von der Arbeit nehmen. Es ist natürlich ein bisschen doof,
dass man das hin- und herschleppen muss. Und was
macht man, wenn man das nicht mitnimmt, weil
man sich denkt, am nächsten Tag kommt man und dann
ist Bahnstreik und kommt nicht. Also,
das ist natürlich, ist natürlich ein bisschen problematisch.
Hey, ich hätte kein Problem. Das Problem ist, was
die bei uns nicht schaffen, ist, äh, mir
einen Windows-Notebook zu geben, wo alles drauf ist, was ich brauche.
Wie gesagt, die haben es bis jetzt
nicht geschafft, mir Rider zu besorgen, beziehungsweise
zu paketieren. Ich hab's,
wir sind jetzt erstmal so weit, dass mein
Chef überhaupt den Antrag stellen konnte.
Also, dass es gekauft wird.
Dass es endlich mal durch ist.
Du kannst keinem Zero trusten.
Das funktioniert nicht. Spätestens deine
Admins können, äh, deine Datenbank
abziehen und ins Darknet verkaufen, wenn sie wollen.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Ich mein, man kann, man kann
sagen,
man, äh,
schaut, dass halt
leichtsinnige Sachen nicht passieren können, ja.
Zum Beispiel, dass man, äh,
unbekannte USB-Geräte
nicht erlaubt oder so. Meinetwegen, ja,
das verstehe ich alles. Ähm,
ja.
Aber das funktioniert nicht.
Du hast
einfach Leute, die kommen an sensible Sachen dran
und denen musst du trauen, sonst, äh,
da frag ich mich, warum du so einstellst.
Zumindest, wenn du von Anfang
an denkst, ich trau ihnen nicht oder irgendwie,
äh, sagen wir mal so, wenn du von Anfang an denkst,
ich trau ihnen nicht, ist ja okay. Aber spätestens,
wenn sie ein Jahr für dich gearbeitet haben und, äh,
nie Scheiße gebaut haben, sollte man sich mal langsam überlegen,
okay, ähm,
ist das, ist das sinnvoll?
Also, du kannst, du schaffst das gar nicht. Du hast immer
Leute, die kommen irgendwo drauf, wo
relevante Informationen liegen,
relevante Daten liegen, die was kaputt machen könnten,
mutwillig irgendwas abziehen könnten,
äh, vom ins Darknet verkaufen,
bis an die Konkurrenz, aber die Leute machen das nicht.
Was ist denn SU2?
Das weiß ich nicht, was das ist.
Brauchst du da Führungszeugnis oder so?
Ja, das könnte man vielleicht auch machen,
aber ganz ehrlich, ich, ich würd mir
ziemlich doof vorkommen, wenn ich, wenn,
wenn, mal angenommen, ich würd mich irgendwo wirklich
noch, noch mal so als, äh,
Linux-Administrator bewerben,
und dann sagt einer
zu mir, ich brauch ein Führungszeugnis,
dann würd ich mir auch denken, was? Weirdchamp,
Alter! Das ist, das
in der Taskleiste, das ist ein Terminal.
Wow, Skip.
Was ist SU2?
Unter
einer Sicherheitsprüfung versteht man, dass Birdchamp
okay, also, Führungszeugnis oder sowas, ne?
Wohnsitz?
Identität? Okay, kein
Führungszeugnis.
Ich hab Half-Life 3 in der Führungs-, äh,
in, in, in der Taskleiste, genau.
Ja, es ist bei uns auch so.
Auf was ich alles Admin-Rechte
im Endeffekt habe, ich könnte,
wenn ich wollte, äh, quasi
für, für
Wochenausfall sorgen, oder,
oder, äh, Zusatz, äh,
Verdienste im Darknet machen, mach ich aber
nicht. Hab ich auch nicht
vor. Also, ich versteh, ich versteh
teilweise diese Ultra-Bedenken nicht,
ähm, gegenüber, gegenüber
Leuten, die, denen
ihr Job das ja quasi ist.
Was willst du machen? Du wirst nicht drauf
verzichten können, manchen Leuten Rechte für ihre
Arbeit gehen zu, äh, geben zu,
zu dürfen.
Also, du musst, du musst für manchen,
du musst manchen Leuten einfach Rechte geben,
dass sie ihre Arbeit machen können. Und umso restriktiver
du bist, umso weniger kannst
du agil sein. Das muss ja auch
allen klar sein, ja? Es wird immer erzählt, so
nach dem Motto, oh, wir sind so super modern
und agil. Es ist ja oftmals einfach nur
vorgeschoben. Die meisten Leute haben noch nicht mal zwei
Sätze gelesen von diesem
Original-Manifest. Ich weiß nicht, hat da, hat da mal
einer von euch reingeguckt?
Zufälligerweise hat
mal einer von euch jemals in dieses,
dieses Original-Agile-Paper
reingeguckt?
Und wie wenig das überhaupt noch mit
der Realität von heute zu tun hat?
Na, egal. Ähm,
das wollte ich
jetzt sagen, genau. Also, umso restriktiver du
bist, umso weniger kannst du agil sein. Das ist
ja klar. Also, wenn du,
also, wenn du beispielsweise sagst, du brauchst
für jeden Handschlag, äh,
ein Formular mit doppeltem Durchschlag
und, äh, zwei Augenverfahren
und sonst was, dann bist du nicht agil.
Das, das, das kann, das eine
und das andere kann nicht zusammen funktionieren.
Du kannst nicht für die simpelsten
Sachen eine halbe Stunde brauchen müssen und dann sagen,
das ist agil. Das, das klappt nicht.
Ich mache gerade Ausbildung, Fachinformatiker,
Entwicklung bin kurz vorm Ende. Ich habe eine Übernahme
bekommen, möchte trotzdem noch,
ist es empfehlenswert, berufsbegleitend
zu stehen oder als Teilzeit? Äh, keine Ahnung.
Kann ich dir leider nix, nix
zu raten. Ich stelle mir aber ganz ehrlich
es ziemlich schwierig vor,
zu
arbeiten und zu studieren.
Dann, dann, dann, dann
machst du ja den ganzen Tag nix anderes.
Dann gehst du arbeiten und dann gehst du, das ist ja
von, also,
was ich, was ich mir eher vorstellen kann,
ist so irgendwie so duales Studium oder sowas,
ja?
Das ist vielleicht eher.
Aber, aber, dass man berufsbegleitend
studieren kann, stelle ich mir sehr ätzend vor.
Also, der Mastercrubber,
der Kumpel vom Friseur und mir aus, aus
Dresden, der hat das ja gemacht.
Der hat ja Informatik studiert, neben
seinen normalen Job, aber der ist halt auch erstens
massive, massive FireQ,
Fivehead, aber auch der
fand das sehr anstrengend.
Du hast eine Schulung für Agile Master
besucht, das ist nur für Mikro-Management.
Das ist ja der Witz. Eigentlich geht es ja
bei agilen, also bei dem ursprünglichen,
ursprünglichen Gedanken, ja,
von agiler Softwareentwicklung geht es ja
darum, möglichst viele
Stonks und Managerleute aus dem
Programmierprojekt oder
Programmier, Programmiereralltag
rauszuwerfen.
Das ist ja der eigentliche Sinn
hinter diesem agilen
Manifest mal gewesen.
Möglichst viele Projektmanager
und Stonksleute auszusperren
erstmal, zu sagen, hey,
ihr habt die Chance, ab und zu was zu dem Projekt
zu sagen und das zu steuern, aber
zwischen diesen Schritten,
das ist ja der Ursprungsgedanken von diesem ganzen agilen
Stelz-Zeugs hier,
aber zwischen diesen
Sprints, also zwischen diesen
Kontrollierschritten
können die Programmierer
machen,
quasi, nein, ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, was sie
wollen, anhand der Vorgaben, aber wie
das dann gemacht wird und was da
wie umgesetzt wird, ist den Programmierern
überlassen und dementsprechend ist die Qualität
besser, als wenn jeder Tag sich in irgendeinem
Manager-Typ was anderes überlegt. Das ist ja
eigentlich der Ursprungsgedanke
hinter diesem,
also die Leute, die sich das mal
ursprünglich ausgedacht haben, hinter diesem ganzen
agilen Zeug. Was da heute
draus gemacht wurde, hat damit ja überhaupt nichts mehr zu tun.
Ist bei uns auch so.
Übrigens,
übrigens, Antivirus, auch witzig,
ich hab ne VM,
ne offizielle VM, über die
wollte ich mal Log-Dateien von nem Linux-Server,
von nem Squid-Server runterkopieren
und das ging nicht. Der hat immer nach 40 MB
abgebrochen, bis ich dann
dahinter gekommen ist, was das ist.
Das war unser Antivirus,
der hat gedacht, das ist irgendein Verschlüsselungsangriff
oder so, weil viele
Dateien mit Schwachsinns-Inhalt geschrieben
wurden. Der Antivirus hat
das Kopieren von Log-Dateien von
einem Squid geblockt, weil er gedacht hat, das ist
irgendeine Verschlüsselungs-Trojaner-Attacke.
Deswegen konnte ich nur
40 MB Logs kopieren.
Das ist alles
so fail, ne? Dann beschwert es sich,
warum es nicht funktioniert.
Du folgst mir, als du noch ein Cod-Kind warst.
Bist du nicht mehr?
Ich bin immer noch
Call-of-Duty-Kind. Hört man doch.
360 No-Scope, Alter.
Was hältst du von Antiviren-Programm?
Nix. Aber der Windows-Defender kann man
schon drauflassen. Aber zusätzliche Sachen
braucht man echt nicht.
Seit Black Ops 2... Ja, ich auch. Ich hab die letzten
kaum noch gespielt. Ich hab Modern Warfare
mal wieder ein bisschen gespielt,
als es rausgekommen ist und dann ist mir aufgefallen,
wie verschissen, also wie
verkackt das Game eigentlich ist,
vom Flow her und dass das Game nicht
weiß, was es sein will.
Dann hab ich sie mal gespielt.
Okay, kommen wir uns an. Hacking Nintendo
Wii Mini. Auf geht's.
Hacker-Mans.
Und zwar das Dringe.
Holst du dir das neue
Cod? Hat das ein Singleplayer?
Ich hab mir Black Ops nur
wegen dem Singleplayer geholt, das letzte Black Ops.
Und
ich muss sagen,
der Singleplayer war nur okay.
Die letzte Mission
war kacke.
Der Build-Up dazu war ganz okay, aber
sag mal so, die Hälfte
von der Black Ops 2 Singleplayer war kacke.
Ein Viertel war gut und ein Viertel
war enttäuschend.
Okay, Hacker-Mans, stell's.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es eine Wii Mini gab.
Ich bin so dumm gewesen.
Ich hab meine N64 und meine
Wii weggeschmissen beim Umzug.
Könnt ihr euch das vorstellen?
Die Spiele hab ich noch.
Aber ich hab die Konsole gedacht und Scheiß
brauch ich eh nie wieder.
Ja, stellt's euch mal vor.
Retailing for 99 dollars,
the Wii Mini was a stripped down Wii
to the bare bones, with only the
ability to load physical Wii
games from disk.
Bisschen leise, oder?
Removed would be the SD-Card-Slot,
its Internet-Capabilities,
Was? Moment, Moment, ernsthaft?
Der Nintendo hat es
geschafft, eine Wii Mini raus
zu bringen, die noch schlechter ist,
quasi Connectivity-mäßig, als die
Original-Wii?
Wie, was?
Naja, gut, das ist Nintendo, weiß ja nie.
KFK 21 Monate, huge subscription.
Big brain.
...Troller and memory card ports.
Not only that, it would contain a modified
version of the Wii Channel, and only
supported composite video signals,
and there was no option to run component
cables at 480p.
There was also no way to play GameCube
games. The idea behind
the Wii Mini was to just play Wii
games without the fuss. Just connect
up to any television and play.
But as a byproduct
of the hardware, while the Wii
has had its security defeated for many years,
the Wii Mini was considered
unhackable, simply because
it has features removed that the existing
Wii exploits rely on.
...features removed that the existing
Ja, ja, ja,
Bannerbomb und solche Geschichten,
die es damals gab. Weiß nicht,
ob einer mal, hat jemand von euch
mal eine Wii geflasht, na, geflasht ist
das falsche Wort, custom, custom
channeled.
Ganz am Anfang hast du noch
Twilight Princess
gebraucht und ein manipulierter Spielstand
und du hast
damals Twilight Princess geladen,
du hast einen manipulierten Spielstand,
wo der Name von deinem Pferd
zu lang war, und wenn
du dann rückwärts zum NPC gelaufen
bist, der den Namen von deinem Pferd
ausgesprochen hat,
bist du zufälligerweise
auf die richtige Speicheradresse
gekommen, um weiteren Code nachladen zu können.
Das war so der erste, das war so der erste
Wii Hack. Danach
gab's Bannerbomb von der
SD-Karte oder vom,
vom, ja, das war dann
einfacher.
Lego Indiana Jones
ging auch, kann sein, kann sein.
Ich kenne nur die Twilight Princess
Geschichte, aber später ging's einfach mit einem
manipulierten Bild
oder so, ja.
The obvious choice might be to somehow
take advantage of... Ach ja, und die
externe Festplatte, um Spiele nachzuladen
für die Wii, die musste
immer am unteren linken
USB-Port angeschlossen sein, ansonsten
ging das nicht. Wahrscheinlich lag
das daran, wie die Sachen in Arbeitsspeicher
gemappt sind oder so.
...of this, and use a USB to LAN
adapter. But this is something Nintendo
had clearly considered when developing
the Wii Mini, and even the official
Nintendo LAN adapter developed for the
Wii is not supported. Huh.
If we take a look at the
current 2021 guide for
Wii-Hacks, there are three that
can be used. STR2
Hacks, Letterbomb, and Flash
Hacks. On the Wii Mini, the
absence of any internet connection renders
the STR2 Hacks unusable.
The popular Letterbomb exploit
requires an SD-Card slot,
which is not available, and Flash
Hacks also requires an internet
connection. Without these methods
that work easily on the Wii,
for years there would be no
easy way to hack the Wii.
...to hack the Wii Mini.
And the hackers mostly
gave up. Perhaps the motivation
wasn't there, as it was just easy
to buy a Wii and hack it
But as always, where there is a will, there is a way.
Every Wii, from the first model out of the production line to the final revision of the Wii Mini,
has one common feature, the controller, known as the Wiimote.
This was the primary game controller for the Wii that features an accelerometer,
a digital buttons, a D-pad and a gyroscope.
Its connectivity to the Wii console is via Bluetooth,
and a sync button on both the console and Wiimote can pair up to four controllers.
Bluetooth then would be the obvious target to exploit,
and in 2019, security researcher known as FullMetal5
announced that an exploit to the Bluetooth stack was discovered found in the Nintendo Wii.
Known as BlueBomb, the exploit takes advantage of a bug
discovered in the Broadcom Bluetooth stack.
It intercepts Bluetooth data between two devices
and uploads a payload to the hardware, which then allows for unsigned content.
Leserate 10 hat contributed.
For a full technical write-up on how the exploit works,
FullMetal5 has a guide on the exploit, how it was discovered and how it was defeated,
and I'll leave a link to that in the description below.
But let's of course test this out for ourselves.
The website, wihacks.guide, will walk you through what you need to do
to perform the BlueBomb exploit on a Wii Mini.
Kann ich danach dann eine externe Platte anschließen, weil ansonsten ist es ja eigentlich ziemlich sinnig, unsinnig.
Richtig pro wäre es natürlich, wenn ich danach ein USB-Hub anschließen könnte
mit Platte und einem Bluetooth-Adapter fürs Internet, aber das wird nicht funktionieren.
No fuss, but you do need a few things.
Namely, a USB-Bluetooth-Adapter and any cheap one on Amazon or eBay should work
and a machine capable of running Linux that supports this adapter.
You could easily install a Linux version...
Moment, hat der Raspberry Pi nicht Bluetooth selbst mit drauf?
Hat der nicht selbst Bluetooth drauf?
Warum brauche ich das?
Warum brauche ich da einen Bluetooth-Adapter?
Alle halbwegs aktuellen haben...
Das ist auch ein neuer, guck mal, der hat blaue USB-Ports, das ist ein 4er.
Der hat doch Bluetooth drauf.
...virtual machine on Windows or similar, but something like a Raspberry Pi with Ubuntu also works...
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Leute.
...that supports this adapter.
You could easily install a Linux virtual machine on Windows or similar, but something like a Raspberry Pi...
...with Ubuntu also works...
Der spricht es falsch aus.
...Jubantil, J-J-J-Jubantil.
Wir wissen alle, dass es Jubantu heißt.
...works and this was my preferred method.
So, to set all this up, first we download the HackMe Installer and copy it to a USB Flash Drive
and then insert that into the back of the Wii Mini.
This Installer contains the HomeBrew Channel and HackMe, which is our entry point for running HomeBrew on any Wii console.
And the Wii Mini is no different.
Then on the Raspberry Pi, simply download the script that will set up the bluebomb exploit.
Run it and enter the information it's asking about your Wii Mini.
In my case, it's USA and NTSC.
Once you've entered everything, the script will then idle with the message waiting to accept.
Ja, ist ja gut mit der Musik jetzt.
Now, let's power up the Wii Mini, but we don't want to enable any Wiimotes.
Now, by pressing the sync button on the Wii Mini, which is the small red button, you will...
...now by pressing the sync button on the Wii Mini, which is the small red button, you will...
Das Ding gibt sich als Fernbedienung aus, oder?
So würde ich das jetzt reininterpretieren, weil man darf ja keine Fernbedienung pairen.
Das heißt, die Wii, also das rate ich jetzt einfach mal,
die Wii Mini macht quasi Bluetooth-Fernbedienungs-Discovery
und der Raspberry Pi tut halt so, als wäre er eine Wii-Fernbedienung
und nutzt dann halt in dieser Bluetooth-Kommunikation zwischen vermeintlicher Fernbedienung
und Wii nutzt er halt irgendwelche Big-Brain-Sachen aus.
At this point we have successfully hacked the Wii Mini.
Bam, rekt.
And now the Hack-Me-Loader will run and bring up a familiar screen.
And from here we can install the Homebrew-Channel.
On a regular Wii we would also install Boot-Me, but this needs SD-Card-Support.
And that's obviously not included on the Wii Mini, so we must skip over this.
So what can you do with a hacked Nintendo Wii Mini?
Well, it turns out, quite a lot.
Nicht wirklich was ohne Internetzugang, oder?
Na gut, vorbei. Wobei. Für was brauchst du? Die meisten Sachen sind ja eh heute down.
... Homebrew-Channel. And this, of course, will allow for all unsigned Homebrew-Apps and games.
And from here I recommend installing Preloader and following the guide to protect from any bricking of the system,
which, of course, is very important.
And from here, well, it's up to you.
But I recommend installing D2X and installing CIOS to allow games to run from USB,
either via using Wii-Flash...
... or the USB-Loader.
Now, one of the more interesting apps that I recommend you take a look at once you've homebrew-modded your Nintendo Wii Mini
is the CleanRip.
And this is something that I would recommend on any Wii system.
And that offers the ability to take your physical media
and insert it into the disk drive
and then allows you to rip your games directly...
Ja.
Ich habe selbstverständlich jegliche
Games, die ich über...
... über den Emulator gespielt habe,
nur so kopiert.
Ich habe mir nie ROMs runtergeladen.
... onto your USB-Stick.
Now, remember, we don't have access to the SD-Card-Slot on the Wii Mini,
but we still have access to the re-USB.
Now, it does take about 25 minutes or so to rip one of the games to disk,
but you can essentially back up your entire Wii-Game-Collection onto USB,
and if you have access to a large USB drive...
Oh, das ist ja sehr schnell.
... then you can take your external USB drive
and the Wii-Mini with you on the road
and have access to all...
Oh, das ist ja sehr schnell.
... all of the Wii-Games without having to bring your collection with you.
The Wii-Mini frustratingly has no Ethernet-Support,
as we mentioned,
but this can also be enabled...
Ah.
... with the Ethernet-Enabler-App by Fullmetal 5,
and this allows the Wii-Mini to connect to the Internet via Ethernet-Cable.
Okay.
It's meant to run once and injects an Ethernet-Configuration
into the system's settings,
something that can normally not be done with the Wii-Mini's system,
and this is pretty awesome stuff.
But perhaps the final omission on the Wii-Mini that can be enabled,
and I think is the coolest feature...
GameCube, ja.
... is the back compat with GameCube games.
Das ist cool.
The tool known as Nintendont will handle this for us.
Der Name wieder.
Nintendont isn't an emulator.
Rather, it takes advantage of the Wii's hardware...
Ja gut, die Wii ist ja im Endeffekt ein GameCube.
Die Wii ist ein GameCube, bisschen höher getaktet.
Die Grafikkarte ist sehr ähnlich.
Das ist ein IBM-Power-PC unten drunter.
... an overclocked GameCube.
Ja, genau, sagt er ja.
While Nintendo removed the ability to read and load GameCube disks,
there is no way that they could remove GameCube support.
And this is a reason why you can use Nintendont on the Wii U.
In any case, Nintendont works really well.
Obviously, you lose the ability to use GameCube controllers,
as the hardware doesn't support them,
but GameCube games run fine from USB,
and you can still use your Wii controllers.
I mentioned that the Wii has a really great and established homebrew scene.
And the choices are really there with what you want to play.
For me, I recommend loading up on emulators,
such as the excellent Genesis GX Plus.
Ja gut, wenn ich Emulator spielen will,
da brauch ich keine gehackte Wii für.
... Master System Emulator.
You'll have an absolutely wonderful time with this.
Ich mein, wenn ich irgendwas emulieren will,
kann ich es auf dem PC wahrscheinlich immer noch am besten machen.
Oder im Zweifelsfall über das Shield-TV,
oder im Wohnzimmer.
But at the end of the day, the Wii Mini still has its limitations.
There's simply no way to re-add an SD-Card
Aber es ist cool, dass es funktioniert.
... progressive scan support,
or add GameCube controllers or memory cards to the hardware,
at least without some major modifications to the hardware itself.
But that really shouldn't be the point.
It's just great to see that almost after a seven year wait,
the Wii Mini can finally be hacked.
And I think that's awesome.
Ja.
... collector's piece to some, and worthless to many others,
finally has some value and purpose,
thanks to the homebrew and modding community.
Now, if you want to hack your own Wii Mini,
I will leave links to everything in the description below.
But for now, we are going to leave it here for this episode.
Thank you so much for watching.
Don't forget to like and subscribe,
and thank you for all the support on...
... Jit-Tipps.
So, mal YouTube nochmal die Chance geben,
vielleicht gibt's ein gescheites Video.
Was denn hack?
Schauen, wo die den Chip hämmern.
Moment, was?
How a Mini Drill Tool Defeated Security.
Das könnte sein, dass wir das schon mal geguckt haben.
Back in 2019, I made a video series about security and the Xbox 360.
In part one, we covered DVD security.
Ich find die Aussprache von der Xbox immer so geil.
Weil in Deutschland, wir haben immer gesagt, Xbox 360.
So, und die Arme sind immer, Xbox 360.
Das klingt, das klingt irgendwie gleich viel...
Summarize.
Kokona-Jäger.
Wusstet ihr eigentlich, dass die CPU von der Xbox 360
und der Playstation 3 von den gleichen Leuten entwickelt wurde?
So, they initially focused on the DVD drive,
with the goal, if we can make the drive believe
that a backup copy of an Xbox 360 game is real,
then there is no need to defeat the hypervisor.
In part one of my series,
I discussed the history of DVD exploits
and how they came to be,
which would become a cat and mouse game.
Die hatten ja auf der Xbox 360,
die haben sich ja jahrelang gefragt,
wie die die ganzen gemordeten Konsolen erkannt haben.
Und das war ja irgendwas auf den CDs drauf.
Sind Xbox und PS3 nicht auch x86?
Nee.
Xbox ist Power-PC und Playstation 3 ist Cell.
Das ist was ganz was anderes.
Game between Microsoft and developer Commodore Forever,
who always seemed to be one step ahead,
releasing custom DVD drive firmwares,
that worked around almost every obstacle Microsoft presented.
Ja.
Including stealth mini trucks, Xbox live bands...
Aber...
Genau, die haben das immer irgendwie gemerkt noch.
... newer anti-piracy and DVD formats.
But inside that timeline,
there was one hack that we didn't mention specifically...
What the fuck?
... and quite possibly...
Aua!
... the craziest console hack ever...
Warum?
Warum machen die das Ding kaputt?
... and that is 2012's kamikaze hack.
Mock AS, Alter!
... because Microsoft...
Hahaha!
... would tighten security on the Xbox 360,
major components of the hardware would all use per console keys,
unique to each hardware device.
And the DVD drive would be no exception.
Microsoft knew that flashing a custom firmware on the DVD drive
would expose their security.
So instead, they would encrypt the firmware via the DVD drive keys.
And flashing a custom firmware required extracting those keys,
which would also be required to rebuild a custom firmware.
In order to re-flash a firmware, the drive would need to be unlocked.
Or in other words, putting the drive into a mode where it can be queried and flashed.
And finally, they would also protect the drive from being flashed
by setting the flash as read-only.
But unfortunately for Microsoft, getting access to the drive's flash
would be one of the very earliest methods to defeat security.
DVD drive mods became quite popular...
Ja.
... because...
... they were chip-ding...
... also, beziehungsweise gemodded, äh, Laufwerke,
das war damals schon so gang und gäbe.
Äh, wobei die immer noch Probleme hatten, wenn du online gespielt hast,
die haben das ja erkannt.
Haben sich gebannt.
... they were easy to perform.
The DVD drive flash would be on a separate chip on the board.
And although Microsoft tried different methods to obfuscate it,
including setting the chip in resin,
so it could not easily have its pins exposed...
Das hat Nintendo ja auch gemacht.
Nintendo hatte mal eine Weile lang komplett Kunstharz in die Wiis reingesprüht,
äh, oder ausgegossen, oder was auch immer,
äh, dass die Leute nicht mal an die Chips drankommen.
... drive was defeated, and custom firmwares were made available.
But in 2012, Microsoft would get creative.
Xbox 360 Slim Models had replaced the earlier FAT Models,
and they knew that they had to do something about the flash chip on the DVD board.
So in certain drives, they would combine the DVD flash chip
with the onboard controller, or DSP, into one package.
This package would also be write-protected,
which would mean that it would not be possible to flash a custom firmware onto this drive.
Also, Microsoft thought.
One of the most popular DVD drives on the Xbox 360 Slim
would be the Liton DG16D4S.
Ah ja.
This drive would contain a Mediatek SoC,
which combined the flash and DSP chip into one package.
The flash chip was pre-installed, and its mode set to write only,
so it couldn't easily be flashed.
And for good measure, the Mediatek chip would be encased in epoxy resin.
Microsoft thought.
Da hat's Microsoft aber echt gut gemeint, oder?
Äh, Chad sagt, ich verstehe diese Aversion gegenüber Custom-Sachen von Nintendo nicht.
Na, die denken, ihnen geht Geld durch die Lappen.
Wobei ich halt der Meinung bin, dass Nintendo gerade immer noch so,
so, so, so beliebt, angesehen und, und, äh,
über lange Jahre lebendig ist,
liegt halt hauptsächlich daran an den Fans und halt an ihrem alten Kram,
der unter anderem auch auf Emulator gespielt werden kann.
Guck mal, es gibt ein komplett eigenes Ökosystem an Speedrun-Turnieren
für A Link to the Past und für Super Mario World, für N64, sonst was.
Wobei, N64, die spielen auf der Originalkonsole,
aber diese ganzen Randomizer-Mods und sowas,
das geht natürlich nur auf dem Emulator.
Ja, ich weiß es auch nicht.
Zumal ich es dann immer witzig finde,
wenn manche Fanprojekte besser sind als die Sachen von Nintendo selbst.
Ja, es ist halt letztendlich,
letztendlich ist Nintendo auch nicht dafür da,
um die Fans glücklich zu machen, sondern für Stonks.
Das hat ja bei Blizzard auch eine Weile gebraucht,
bis die Leute das gecheckt haben,
dass Blizzard nicht nett ist, sondern Blizzard einfach nur Stonks machen will,
egal was Sache ist,
und es da schon lange nicht mehr irgendwie um die Fans geht.
Natürlich labern die alle rum, so nach dem Motto,
oh ja, wir haben die größten, besten Fans, sonst wie,
ja, solange sie Geld ausgeben.
Ja, und Blizzard und Nintendo auch,
denen geht es nie um irgendwelche,
wie soll ich sagen, nie um irgendwelche Sachen,
denen geht es immer nur um sich selbst.
Und ich glaube, das haben jetzt mittlerweile gerade bei Blizzard
auch die letzten Leute verstanden,
wobei es ja immer noch so ein paar Hardcore-Verteidiger gibt.
Bei Blizzard, bei Blizzard siehst du es halt auch ganz krass, ne?
Zum Beispiel, ähm, als diese,
kann sie, vielleicht könnt ihr euch noch daran erinnern,
als diese Geschichte war mit Black Life Matters,
da war, oder was ist die, das ist ja immer noch,
äh, da waren sie ganz groß dabei, haben das supportet,
haben, haben Overwatch-Events gemacht,
haben teilweise Custom-Skins und so rausgehauen,
waren voll dabei, ja?
Da, wenn man sich dieses Event als einziges anschaut,
könnte man sagen, okay, äh, Blizzard,
ich mein, das sind ja ne Firma aus den USA,
die fanden das wichtig zu unterstützen
und, und standen da dahinter und wollten das supporten.
Okay, so weit, so gut.
Wär ich auch noch mitgegangen, aber,
dann kam danach,
oder, umgedreht, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was zuerst war,
dann kam dieser Vorfall
mit die, mit dem, äh,
Hearthstone-Spieler aus Hongkong,
der gesagt hat, irgendwie, äh, Free Hongkong
oder irgendwie sowas, wo dann
das Preisgeld eingezogen wurde von nem Jahr,
er von Turnieren gebannt wurde
und die Caster, äh,
quasi rausgeworfen wurden,
die zufälligerweise auch noch im Bild waren.
Und da hat man spätestens wieder gesehen,
es geht Blizzard nicht irgendwie um ne bessere Welt,
um Menschenrechte oder sonstwas,
es geht Blizzard schlicht und ergreifend
einfach nur um Stonks!
Die sind genau
auf ihrer Seite und sonst auf
keiner anderen Seite. Und wenn ihre Seite
es nützt, für etwas
zu sein, dann sind sie dafür, und wenn es
ihre Seite nutzt, dagegen zu sein, dann sind sie dagegen.
Das ist denen einfach
wurscht. Die sind einfach nur bei sich
auf ihrer Seite.
Jetzt benennen sie McCree um.
Stimmt, stimmt, sie benennen McCree um.
Ähm,
frag mich, frag mich, frag mich, wie McCree
dann heißt. Wobei das Witzige ist,
in einem der McCree-Comics, so als ich
noch Overwatch Lore verfolgt habe,
wurde sogar angedeutet, dass McCree
wohl nur ein Fake-Name ist.
Das könnte man sogar
ganz gut einbinden.
Ich muss mal ganz ehrlich sagen, ich finde das
okay, dass sie das umbenennen.
Ich hab da nix dagegen. Es gibt ja Leute, die sind da voll am Wetter
und sagen, oh, das ist ein Videogame-Charakter.
Hey, wenn es nach einem der Leute
benannt ist, die sich da bei
Blizzard nicht so mit Ruhm bekleckert haben, ist
okay, verstehe ich, dass man das umbenennt.
Ähm,
dass dadurch irgendeinem
aber geholfen wird am Ende,
das bezweifle ich. Also das ist
auch ein typischer Blizzard-Stonks-Move,
dass McCree umbenannt wird.
Das ist der Stonks-Move, schaut her, wir machen was.
Blizzard geht es überhaupt
nicht darum, die Welt irgendwie besser zu machen
oder irgendwie ein Zeichen zu setzen oder sonst was.
Bobby hat gesagt, Jungs,
sorgt mal dafür,
dass es so aussieht, als kümmern wir uns
drum und machen was. Was können wir denn machen?
Ja, äh, lass McCree umbenennen.
An sich ist es
vollkommen gerechtfertigt, aber
die machen das nicht aus dem Grund,
dem sie
einem glauben machen wollen,
sie würden es machen. Sie machen das nämlich einfach nur
für sich. Dass die Welt
guckt und sagt, hey, guck mal da,
Blizzard macht was.
In Wirklichkeit machen sie es nur für sich,
dass sie wieder besser dastehen.
Wobei, was ich auch wieder geil fand,
Twitter ist ja komplett
wieder übers Ziel herausgeschossen,
ich habe gelesen,
auf Twitter hat einer geschrieben,
so sinngemäß, wer einen seiner
Coworker nach einem Date fragt,
sollte quasi
geächtet werden oder sowas. Da habe ich mir gedacht,
Alter, in welcher Welt leben die Leute
auf Twitter eigentlich? Ich glaube,
ich kann es euch jetzt nicht in Prozent sagen,
aber ein Großteil,
also ein nicht unerheblicher Teil
der Paare
lernen sich auf der Arbeit kennen.
Man kann ja nicht so
realitätsfremd sein und sagen, ah,
das ist nicht so.
Also,
Twitter hat
teilweise komplett in die entgegengesetzte
Richtung wieder übers Ziel hinausgeschossen.
Also,
es ist halt Twitter.
Es ist halt Twitter.
Twitter sind wirklich schon die ganz fertigen
Leute am Start.
Ich sehe da überhaupt kein Problem drin,
auf der Arbeit irgendjemand,
egal ob männlich, weiblich, wie auch immer,
zu fragen.
Man muss halt akzeptieren, weil einer sagt, habe ich kein
Bock.
Und vielleicht sollte man auch nicht als Chef
hingehen und seine Machtposition ausnutzen.
Das sind ja zwei unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe.
Aber wenn du Leute hast, die, keine Ahnung,
seit drei Jahren zusammenarbeiten,
sich vielleicht auch so schon zueinander hingezogen
fühlen und er sie dann
fragt oder umgedreht, das ist ja in der heutigen Zeit
kein Problem, wollen wir vielleicht nach
der Arbeit nochmal irgendwie was essen
gehen oder so, ist doch überhaupt
kein Problem.
Das wurde auf Twitter wieder komplett
verteufelt. Es hat wirklich einer geschrieben,
das sollte geächtet werden.
Da habe ich gedacht, fuck, was ist mit euch wieder los?
Egal, gucken wir mal weiter.
Ich habe übrigens, ich habe meine
Xbox damals nicht gemoddet.
Ich habe meine Xbox nicht gemoddet.
Ich glaube, der Fabian hatte eine,
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob der Frazier eine gemoddete
Xbox hatte. Der Fabian hatte
eh gefühlt fünf Xbox und 20 Accounts.
XX, der Friseur,
I, Frazier,
der Friseur,
der Friseur XX.
Der Fabian hatte 20 Accounts oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Das habe ich jetzt verstanden.
Ja.
Hm.
Wie kommt man da überhaupt drauf?
Wie man da drauf kommt, das kann ich mir in dem Fall sogar vorstellen, wie man da drauf kommt.
Irgendjemand hat auf den Chip geguckt, hat sich die Schematics geholt von dem Mediatek-Chip
und hat sich angeguckt, wo könnte ich da was bohren müssen, dass das nicht mehr ride protected ist.
Also ich gehe mal davon aus, dass du die Schaltpläne für diesen Mediatek-Chip im Internet findest.
Oder irgendjemand hat es aufgemacht und sich unter dem Mikroskop angeguckt.
Siehste? Siehste? Mikroskop.
Obviously. Natürlich. Welche, welche Lines denn sonst?
Na also, das erkennt ja nun wirklich jeder, dass das hier die Ride Protection ist.
Also Chat, wer von euch nicht erkennt, dass diese zwei Adern der Schreibschutz sind,
dann habt ihr ja nicht aufgepasst im Stream.
Ja.
Obviosly!
So geil!
So geil! Wir sind einfach durch Sport!
By the way, es hätte schon mal seinen Vorteil gehabt, wenn man den Drill gerade reingemacht hat.
Guck mal, wie shabt das ist!
Getting through this, but the element of risk would always be there.
...first version of the hack would require you to strip away the epoxy resin and drill the hole based on the offset of pins both across and down later on you can buy a simple tools
Siehste!
hat man von den Griechen gelernt, dass man so, so und so, wenn man das dann macht, dass
man exakt auf der gleichen Position rauskommt. Man kann natürlich nur hoffen, dass die Pins
immer exakt gleich sind. Jawoll, das habe ich mir gedacht, dass es dadurch irgendwelche
Schablonen für gibt.
Was ist das da oben?
Hä? Dass du nicht durchbohrst? Ja gut, wenn du durch die Platine bohrst, ist natürlich
auch doof.
Jemand hat Erfahrung mit Klonen als Gyrasorber.
Äh, inwiefern? Linux-Kiste? Kannst du einfach die Platte de-dehn?
... sehr langsam, dann rinzen und wiederholen. Aber leider weiß nicht jeder, wie man den
Hack ausführen kann. Hier ist ein Beispiel, das nicht so gut funktioniert hat. Aber das
Endresultat wäre ein erfolgreiches Drive-Unlock, und dann könntest du Commodore 4Evers custom
White-Touch-Firmware flashen und DvDs auf deinem Xbox 360 spielen. Der Kamikaze-Hack,
während es riskant war, war ein...
Ist im produktiven Netz. Also die einfachste Variante, einen Server zu klonen unter Linux,
wo man sich nicht viel Gedanken machen muss, ist DvD von der einen Platte runter und auf
eine andere Platte drauf. Kannst du auch über das Netzwerk machen.
... und du kannst einfach booten davon danach.
... und dann hast du das Pin genommen, das saniert wurde, und du hast es in der den
exacten Position gehalten, während du das Power zum VCC verkaufst, und es gibt ein
LED-Licht dazu. Also bist du weiter drücken, drücken, drücken, bis die LED-Licht aufrollt
wird. Das bedeutet, du hast die richtige Einancia-Pin auf dem Flaschschiff. Okay, nachdem du
sie genommen hast, dann verbinde du den gesamten Side-of-Drive mit deinem PC und programmierst
die richtige Einsknalle.
... die neue Einsknalle hat jetzt...
... Die neue Einsknalle hat jetzt...
Das ist schon echt hardcore, kann man nicht anders nennen.
Mir ist gerade auch ein Video eingefallen, was ich gucken wollte.
Ich wollte mir ein Video angucken.
Ich habe gesehen,
die GameStar, Maurice von der GameStar,
das sind fast die einzigen Videos, die ich mir da noch angucke,
hat sich drüber ausgelassen.
Ich weiß nicht, okay, das ist 18 Minuten.
Aber der hat abgenommen, oder?
Der hat mega abgenommen.
Was ist denn da los?
Guck mal hier, der hat Ultra abgenommen.
Der ist jetzt wahrscheinlich
voll der Schrank
unter dem Shirt.
Aber 18 Minuten ist mal fast ein bisschen
lang.
Ja, weil ich wollte mir das kaufen,
zur Release.
Und irgendwie hat er sich
darüber ausgelassen, warum es sackt.
Egal, wir gucken uns das jetzt trotzdem an.
Ich habe es noch nicht geguckt.
Vielleicht ist es auch halb so wild.
Die Beta von Diablo 2 Resurrected
hat zwei Dinge klar gemacht.
Erstens, Diablo 2
ist immer noch...
Die Beta war deutlich zu kurz. Es ging bloß bis Akt 2.
Das hast du ja ein paar Stunden durch,
wenn du geübt bist.
... der besten Spiele aller Zeiten.
Wozu haben die das Ganze jetzt nochmal gemacht?
Also warum sollte man die Riot Protection umgehen wollen?
Ach so, du meinst,
wegen dem Hack?
Naja, dass du das Laufwerk
flashen kannst.
Ah, guck mal, Chainlaw ist auch da.
Du konntest Custom Firmware auf dein DVD-Laufwerk
flashen. Microsoft hat allerdings
einen Chip drauf gemacht, der Riot Protected
war und du konntest es nicht mehr flashen.
Wenn du es geflasht hast, konntest du selbstgebrannte
DVDs abspielen, mit Xbox spielen.
So, dementsprechend mussten sie da reinbohren
und die Riot Protection
für den Chip ausschalten,
damit du Custom Firmware flashen kannst.
Und wenn du Custom Firmware geflasht hast,
dann konntest du
selbstgebrannte Xbox-DVDs
oder selbstgebrannte DVDs mit Xbox-Spielen spielen.
Aber zweitens, es ist trotzdem
in manchen Bereichen...
Also ich muss sagen, grafisch fand ich das richtig gut gemacht.
Ich hab ja die Beta auch gespielt, nachdem ich auf Twitch
Twitch-Zugang
bekommen hab. Grafisch ist das,
hab ich selten gesehen,
dass das lauter...
Hab ich selten gesehen, dass
ein Remake wirklich so
das Original
widerspiegelt, nur in besseren
Qualität.
Richtig schlecht gealtert.
Und ich find's einen riesen Fehler, dass die Entwickler
sich weigern, das Spiel in diesen
Bereichen zu verbessern.
Okay, lass mich raten. Ich weiß jetzt schon,
worüber er meckert. Ich predikte mal.
Ich predikte mal.
Er meckert, dass man nur mit F-Tasten
die Skills
durchschalten kann.
Weil in Diablo 2 ist es so, du hast jetzt nicht etwa
linke Maustaste, rechte Maustaste,
mittlere Maustaste,
WASD und sonst was.
Und in Diablo 2 hast du nur Skills
auf der rechten oder der linken Maustaste
und du musst die Skills mit F1
bis F8 oder so durchschalten.
Da wird er drüber meckern. 100 pro.
Ähm...
Und ansonsten...
Also das ist auch
das Erste, was mir aufgefallen ist, wo ich mir gedacht hab,
okay, das ist halt oldschool,
aber ist halt
irgendwie 2021
nicht mehr das.
Über was könnte er denn
sonst noch meckern?
Ah, dass man nicht mehr offline spielen kann
vielleicht. Ich glaub, das geht nämlich
nicht mehr. Ich glaub, man kann nicht mehr offline spielen.
Zumindest ging das in der Beta nicht. Okay, gucken wir mal.
Nee, Diablo 2 streame ich
nicht. Das ist langweilig zu gucken.
Es folgt für mich von einem fundamentalen Fehlverständnis
dafür, was eine
perfekte Neuauflage
im Herzen wirklich ausmacht.
Erzähl's uns, Maurice.
Aber wie wir alle wissen, bin ich
der ultimative Diablo
Overlord. Und Blizzard macht
alles, was sie wollen. Er hat voll
abgenommen, ey. Der hat hier
den Fitness-Crime gemacht.
Ja, leider konnte man
in der Beta kein Nekro spielen.
Nekro ist die Easy-Mode-Startklasse
schlechthin in dem Game.
Ah, okay.
Activision Blizzard wird derzeit
vom Staat Kalifornien verklagt.
Für angeblich katastrophale
und entwürdigende Arbeitsbedingungen,
die sich über Jahre
hinweg durch die Firma gezogen haben sollen.
Das musst du erst mal schaffen,
dass sich der Staat Kalifornien
verklagt. Nicht irgendein
ehemaliger Mitarbeiter. Nein.
Kalifornien verklagt dich.
Und ich kann jeden verstehen, der unter
diesen Umständen sagt,
diese Firma
will ich boykottieren.
Ich persönlich habe mich
trotzdem entschieden, weiter über
Blizzard-Spiele zu berichten, denn
die werden ja nicht nur von den Chefs
da oben gemacht, die für die Arbeitsbedingungen
verantwortlich sind, sondern auch und vor allem
von den ganzen Entwicklern
am Boden, die darunter gelitten haben
und trotzdem ihr Herzblut
in diese Spiele gesteckt haben.
Diese Entwickler kämpfen aktuell
für ein besseres Blizzard
und ich persönlich wünsche mir
so sehr, dass sie damit Erfolg
haben, dass sie Blizzard zu einer
Firma machen, deren Spiele
ich wieder guten Gewissens einfach
nur lieben kann.
Dabei würde ich sie nicht unterstützen,
wenn ich einfach gar nicht mehr über ihre Arbeit
berichten würde. Stattdessen
will ich weiter darüber berichten,
sowohl über die Spiele, als
auch über die Bedingungen. Über das Gute
wie das Schlechte.
Das ist sehr diplomatisch gesagt.
Wir haben ein sehr ausführliches Video zu diesem ganzen Skandal
mit meinen Kollegen Heiko und Leia gemacht.
Das empfehle ich euch, wenn ihr euch darüber
mehr informieren wollt, denn es ist ein
enorm wichtiges Thema, dass man nicht
totschweigen sollte. Aber wie gesagt,
will ich auch über die Spiele
weiterhin reden und
darum soll es heute gehen.
Fangen wir mal an damit,
was meine ich denn, wenn ich...
Chat sagt, die Corona-Pass-App ist
Two-Head, die kann keine
Ö-Ä-Üs anzeigen.
Kann sie Emojis anzeigen? Das ist eigentlich das
Wichtige. Wer braucht Umlaute, wenn Emojis gehen?
Ich sage, Diablo 2 ist in manchen Bereichen
schlecht gealtert. Ich meine damit
vor allem einen Bereich,
Nennung und Spielkomfort.
Man könnte sich da jede Menge Beispiele raussuchen.
Das umständliche Tränke-Management,
das viel zu kleine Inventar,
in dem ich nicht mal...
Ja, das stimmt, das stimmt, das stimmt.
Das Inventar ist auch so ein Ding.
Das ist zwar nah am Original dran,
aber
gerade das Rumhantieren mit den Tränken,
weiß ich nicht, ob das hätte sein
gemusst. Ich persönlich habe mir ja gedacht,
als ich die Beta gespielt habe,
ihr kennt das vielleicht, oder für die Leute, die Diablo 2
gespielt haben, später wird das so aussehen,
dass in dem Inventar gar kein Platz mehr drin ist,
weil du das Inventar quasi
bis auf wenige Slots
voll hast mit Charms,
die Stats steigern.
Also ich hätte es durchaus für sinnvoll gefunden,
wenn man das so macht, wie beispielsweise Path of Diablo
das gemacht hat.
Das ist ja quasi ein Mod.
Habe ich hier irgendwo? Da.
Das ist ein Mod für
Diablo 2 gewesen. Die haben ein
extra Charms-Inventory.
Du kannst auch nicht mehr Charms,
also Glücksbringer,
mit Stats-Bonus ins Inventar legen,
wie in Vanilla,
aber du hast auch ein zweites Inventar für
Drops, was ich sehr, sehr sinnvoll fand.
Ich wusste es.
Ich wusste es, dass es kommt.
Und F1 bis F8 oder so.
Ja.
Welche Fähigkeit auf der Maustaste
liegt, um dann die Maustaste
drücken zu müssen, um sie auszulösen.
Und dann zu wechseln und wieder die Maustaste
Das ist wirklich nicht zeitgemäß.
Das ist doch absurd
aus heutiger Sicht, wo sich seit
Jahren die Skill-Leiste mit
Hotkeys als Genre-Standard etabliert
hat, wo ich einfach mit einem
Knopfdruck direkt die Fähigkeit meiner
Wahl auslösen kann.
Und das ist einfach ein positiv
besseres System. Das System von Diablo 2
tut nichts.
Außer mehr Knopfdrücke hinzuzufügen
und damit den Kampflust zu verschlechtern.
Und dass die Entwickler das nicht verbessern
wollen, ist doppelt bizarr,
weil es gibt ein besseres System
in Diablo 2 Resurrected.
Aber halt nur fürs Gamepad.
Wenn ich ein Gamepad am PC anschließe,
wechselt das Spiel sofort zu einem
Menü mit Fähigkeitenleiste.
Ja, warum macht man das nicht?
Warum macht man das nicht optional?
Das ist tatsächlich deutlich, deutlich
komfortabler und besser in 2021.
Es ergibt in Diablo 2 auch wirklich keinen Sinn,
das weiterhin so zu machen.
Es ist trotzdem jeder Skill unabhängig
voneinander. Also wäre es beispielsweise
so gewesen, in Diablo 2, aus Balancing-Gründen,
dass wenn man den Skill switcht,
dass der alte Skill dann aufhört zu wirken.
Das hätte ich verstanden, dass man das
aus Balancing-Gründen dann beibehält.
Aber das ist ja gar nicht so.
Das ist ja gar nicht so.
Du kannst in Diablo 2 ohne Probleme
rüber switchen, Pads beschwören und dann
auf einen anderen Skill switchen und die
Pads bleiben trotzdem da.
Ja, du kannst irgendwie Firewall
irgendwo hinsetzen, Skill switchen und es
ist immer noch da.
Also aus dem Gesicht, es gibt eigentlich
überhaupt keinen Sinn, es nicht so zu machen.
Ja, da gäbe ich ihm im Rechner.
Passt mal auf, ich könnte das mit
Controller-Emulator spielen.
Ich spiele am Rechner,
mit Maus und Tastatur, tue aber so,
als wäre es ein Controller.
Next Level.
Obwohl Dutzende Spiele gezeigt haben,
dass das auch für Maus und Tastatur
das naheliegendste Interface für diese Art von Spiel ist.
Und es ist einfach ein Beispiel,
wo Entwickler im Laufe der Jahre gelernt haben,
wie man so ein Interface besser gestaltet.
Warum bleibt das nicht mehr auf?
Die Mechanik von Diablo 2 hat hier keinen intrinsischen Wert,
die zu behalten ist für mich.
Einen intrinsischen Wert?
Kein Fall von die Seele von Diablo 2 zu bewahren.
Das ist einfach eine veraltete Steuerungsmechanik,
die das Spiel nicht verbessert und auch keinen großen
nostalgischen Wert oder sowas hat.
Das heißt so viel wie keinen inneren Antrieb oder inneren Wert.
Es gibt in meinen Augen drei potenzielle Gründe.
Der erste ist einfach Ehrfurcht vor dem Original.
Sie wollen dem Geist des Klassikers so treu bleiben wie möglich.
Und das verstehe ich total.
Das ist enorm wichtig.
Jede Modernisierung birgt die Gefahr,
dass man sich damit zu weit vom Kern des Originals entfernt
und das Spiel vielleicht sogar verschlechtert.
Aber was ist denn der Kern von Diablo 2?
Wenn ihr euch mal zurück...
Ich glaube, ich glaube, dass das sehe ich ein bisschen anders.
Ja, es wird bestimmt Ehrfurcht vor dem Original sein.
Aber dafür hast du ja eigentlich so was wie einen Director.
Ja, also der im Prinzip so Sachen...
Äh...
Wie soll ich sagen?
So, so, so, so Wege, wie das, wie das gemacht wird, erproben lässt, festlegt, so wie das,
wie das werden soll.
Also quasi irgendein Regisseur, quasi sowas in der Richtung oder irgendein Projektleiter
oder keine Ahnung.
Und ich glaube einfach, dass sie selbst keine Ahnung mehr haben, was den Geist des Originals
ausmacht.
Das glaube ich bei vielen Remakes mittlerweile.
Dass sie es remade.
Weil es Geld bringt und sie aber eigentlich gar keine Ahnung mehr haben von der Essenz des
Originals.
Wenn ihr euch zurück erinnert, warum ihr dieses Spiel immer noch in so liebevolle Erinnerung
habt und warum ihr es vielleicht auch heute gerne noch spielt, was ist denn dann der Grund
dafür?
Ich denke dann zum Beispiel an die großartige Atmosphäre von Diablo 2.
Ja.
An diesen düsteren Horror, den bis heute kaum ein anderes Hack and Slay so gut eingefangen
hat.
Ich denke an das brillante Klassendesign, an die vielfältigen und richtig coolen Skilltrees
für jeden Helden.
Der Nekromant aus Diablo 2 ist bis heute...
Da muss ich was zu sagen, Chat.
Chat.
Also.
Was nervt dich eigentlich am meisten an deinem Beruf?
Ich bin Programmierer und am meisten nervt es sich, wenn sich Leute dauernd beschweren,
aber dann auch nichts machen wollen, um es zu verbessern.
Also was mich nervt, das hat wenig was damit zu tun, ob ich jetzt Sachen programmiere oder
sonst wie was.
Das liegt jetzt aber, wie gesagt, das ist nicht direkt das, was mich an meinem Beruf
nervt, sondern dort, wo ich arbeite, dass Entscheidung und Umsetzung oftmals nichts
miteinander zu tun hat.
Also es wird irgendwas Abstraktes entschieden.
Also okay, ich mach mal, ich mach mal ein Beispiel, ich mach mal ein Beispiel.
Also bei uns ist die beste Variante, um auf Neuerungen zu reagieren, einfach zwei Monate
abzuwarten.
Weil von 90 Prozent der Neuerungen hörst du nach zwei Monaten nichts mehr, weil sie irrelevant
sind.
Weil man sie doch nicht mehr haben will.
Also es kommt irgendjemand und sagt, hey Max, es ist jetzt ganz wichtig xy zu machen,
dann machst du einfach zwei Monate xy nicht.
Und wenn xy nach zwei Monaten immer noch relevant ist, dann kannst du damit anfangen.
Es werden bei uns wöchentlich neue Dinger und Änderungen und Sachen verkündet und
immer mit einem Nachdruck, so als wäre das jetzt das Wichtigste von der Welt und von
90 Prozent der Sachen hörst du nie wieder was.
Selfmade-Eyes, dankeschön für die 14 Monate Hype.
Das nervt mich, das, das nervt mich und was mich persönlich ein bisschen nervt ist, also
so aus dem, so aus dem Umfeld, dass man, wie soll ich sagen, schwer, dass die Leute es
schwer erkennen, was man, was man eigentlich, warum man manche Sachen braucht, ja.
Zum Beispiel ist es bei uns lange Zeit so gewesen, wir hatten Linux-Notebooks, womit
du Linux mit Abstand am besten administrieren kannst.
Ja.
Aber sie sind jetzt seit Jahren schon hinterher, dass wir auch alle Windows-Notebooks verwenden,
aber es haut nie hin.
Es haut nie hin, weil immer irgendwelche Dinger da nicht richtig ordentlich funktionieren.
Also sie sind auf der einen Seite nicht in der Lage, unser Windows-Zeug ordentlich zu
machen, aber auf der anderen Seite sagen sie nach dem Motto, Leute, ihr dürft kein Linux
mehr verwenden, was dazu führt, dass man permanent in so einem halblegalen Grauzonenbereich
operatet.
Das, das ist auch ein absolutes Unding, meiner Ansicht nach.
Ne, habe ich nicht gehört, aber ich habe vom Alan Wake Remake gehört, was ich sehr
nice finde, weil Alan Wake eines der besten Spiele überhaupt ist.
Wobei ich mir ehrlich gesagt eher eine Fortsetzung erhofft hätte, weil das Ending von Alan Wake
jetzt nicht so erfüllend war, ja.
Ja, du kannst über PayPal bezahlen in Indien, YouTube.
Hast du gesubchained nur?
Da kam ja überhaupt nichts.
Ach da, doch, hier.
Massive Subscription, neuer.
Huge.
Habe ich nicht gesehen.
Hast du Control gespielt?
Ja, aber Control habe ich abgebrochen.
Das war das erste Remedy-Spiel, was ich nicht durchgespielt habe, weil ich das einfach nur
langweilig fand.
Mich hat die Story nach irgendwie 10 Stunden nichts oder, ja, na, so lange habe ich nicht
gespielt.
Sag mal, irgendwie 5, 6 Stunden nicht sonderlich gepackt und das Gameplay fand ich auch nicht
gut.
Nicht so spannend.
Ja, also Control.
Ist das erste Remedy-Game, was ich nicht, was ich nicht durchgespielt habe.
So, gucken wir mal weiter.
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Genau.
Der beste Totenbeschwörer, den man in irgendeinem Rollenspiel spielen kann.
Das stimmt.
Nekro ist das Beste.
Ich denke an die Suchtspirale, die Diablo 2 ja überhaupt erst kodifiziert hat.
Nekro ist die absolute Noob-Klasse in Diablo 2.
Also wer keine Ahnung hat, mit was er starten soll, startet Nekro.
Einfach ganz normales Summoning-Bild, Easy-Mode.
Easy-Mode bis, bis, bis schwierigster Schwierigkeitsgrad.
Standard für dieses Genre gesetzt hat.
Und ich denke an den perfekten Spagat aus Tiefgang und Zugänglichkeit, den bis heute
kaum ein anderes Spiel so gut geschafft hat wie Diablo 2.
Das stimmt.
Diablo 3 zum Beispiel ging vielen schon zu sehr.
Ja.
Diablo 3 fand ich zu langweilig.
Das stimmt.
POE ist, das ist übrigens das POE 2, was immer noch nicht raus ist.
Wann kommt eigentlich Path of Exile 2?
Wollen die es nicht schon letztes Jahr releasen?
Ja.
Ähm.
Das ist wirklich extrem hardcore.
Kompliziert zu umständlich.
Wann ist denn Path of Exile 2 Release jetzt eigentlich?
Warte mal.
Frühestens 2022.
Okay.
Dauert noch ewig.
Path of Exile 2 saß lange vor diesen beiden Spielen in einer perfekten Mitte zwischen
diesen beiden Punkten und hat es damit geschafft...
Die haben POE mit der letzten Liga getötet.
Das habe ich gelesen.
Da haben die total viele Sachen genervt und angepasst.
Und es waren ganz viele gepisst.
Ich habe die letzten drei Ligen nicht gespielt.
Ich habe nur am Rande mitbekommen, was was war.
Sie wollten ja ursprünglich was machen.
Dass die Leute quasi nur noch selbst durch die Maps springen.
Aber sie haben es wohl nicht geschafft, diese Instant Death Momente zu fixen.
Also ich habe es nicht richtig mitgekriegt, was Path of Exile passiert ist.
Aber nächste Liga sind die Leute doch wieder am Start, wenn die Sache gefixt ist.
Spieler anzusprechen und zu begeistern.
Und in dieses Genre zu führen.
Das sind die Dinge, die für mich Diablo 2 ausmachen.
Und diese Tugenden bewahrt Diablo 2.
Ja, hat er recht.
Ich will ja hier gar nicht sagen, dass die Entwickler hier ein komplett deplatziertes Remake produzieren.
Im Gegenteil.
Die Grafik zum Beispiel ist der Hammer.
Ich war absolut begeistert.
Ja, das stimmt.
Wie nah am Original das dran ist.
Ja, wirklich gut.
Aber trotzdem dem Geist des Originals so wunderbar treu bleiben.
Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Das ist vorbildlich für diese Art von Neuauflage.
Und das sind eben die Bereiche, wo das für mich zählt.
Wo Originaltreue wichtig ist.
Aber niemand erinnert sich doch daran zurück, wie toll es war, dass wir damals die Fähigkeiten nur mit den Maustasten steuern konnten.
Wie toll es war, dass wir dafür nur zwei Buttons hatten.
Das stimmt.
Für mich hat es halt zu dem Game dazu gehört, weil ich gesagt habe, es ist halt so.
Aber er hat schon recht.
Also das andere System ist einfach besser.
Woran irgendwer denkt, wenn er sich heute zurück erinnert.
Zumal es ja auch keinen mechanischen Grund da irgendwie gibt.
Und das denkt auch niemand, der heute Path of Exile spielt.
Ah verdammt, diese modernen Spiele sind doch echt alle viel zu dumm.
Jetzt habe ich hier mehrere Buttons für meine Fähigkeiten.
Ich wünschte, ich hätte nur wie damals in Diablo 2 meine Maustasten.
Das ist etwas, was in meinen Augen...
Was Steam... Moment, mein Steam Charts Path of Exile... Moment, das musst du mir jetzt mal angucken.
Hier kam wahrscheinlich... Hier war eine Season.
Hä?
Wann ist denn die letzte Season gestartet?
War die hier?
Ist das Beginn? Letzte Season?
Viel zu lang.
Ging das nicht nur zwei Monat... Drei Monate ging das?
Ja gut, der Trend ist aber der gleiche, wenn man jetzt mal nicht so die Anzahl anguckt.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Ich sage nämlich, das war nämlich fucking beliebt nach Steam Release.
Gut, hier ist Corona.
Hier ist halt volle Pulle Corona in der Zeit wieder hier.
Aber das geht deutlich härter nach unten als bei den anderen Seasons.
Hier geht es auch nach unten Season Ende, aber hier geht es tatsächlich eine ganze Ecke...
Eine ganze Ecke mehr.
Wobei...
Ja, großen Unterschied macht es eigentlich gar nicht.
...Wert hat bewahrt zu werden.
Es ist einfach nur das Bewahren einer objektiv schlechteren Mechanik aus, in diesem Fall,
eine unplatzierte Ehrfurcht vor dem Original.
Und das versteht für mich fundamental falsch, was das Ziel einer perfekten Neuauflage eigentlich ist.
Für mich geht es bei dieser Art von Neuauflage darum, uns Spielern das gleiche Gefühl zu geben,
das wir damals hatten, als wir das Spiel zum ersten Mal...
Das stimmt, aber das wird schwierig.
...und auch neuen Spielern, die heute erst reinkommen, das gleiche Gefühl zu geben, wie ich damals hatte,
als ich in meiner Kindheit zum ersten Mal Diablo 2 gestartet habe.
Oh, ob das funktioniert?
Und dazu gehört zum Beispiel die Grafik fundamental aufzubauen, denn damals war die ja nicht veraltet.
Diablo 2 sah jetzt nie umwerfend aus, aber es war damals...
Man muss sagen, das hat mich damals schon nicht wirklich vom Hocker gehauen.
Ich hatte einen Rechner, der hatte zu wenig RAM, als ich angefangen habe mit Diablo 2.
Es hat geruckelt as fuck.
Aber das sah okay aus, wobei es schon durchaus Besseres gab.
Haltet.
Bei Diablo 2 kam wann? 1998 oder so raus?
Wenn ich heute das gleiche Gefühl wie damals haben will, muss die Grafik nicht mehr veraltet aussehen.
Und das tut sie auch nicht. Sie haben das ja wirklich aufwendig neu gestaltet.
Aber das Gleiche gilt für mich zum Beispiel für die Bedienung.
Damals hat die sich für mich nicht umständlich und veraltet angefühlt, weil ich kann es ja nicht besser.
Ich kam von Diablo 1, das noch umständlicher war, und da war Diablo 2 eine Verbesserung.
Heute fühlt sich das altmodisch und altmodisch an.
Altmodisch und veraltet an.
Was es damals nicht war.
Nahkampfcharacters lowlevel hier. In a nutshell.
Und wenn man heute das gleiche Gefühl haben will wie damals, muss in meinen Augen auch der Komfort ein paar Sprünge machen,
damit ich heute nicht reinkomme und denke, so spielt man das doch eigentlich heutzutage nicht.
Denn diesen Gedanken hatte ich ja damals nicht, als ich Diablo 2 gespielt habe.
Und das beste Beispiel, der beste Beweis für mich...
Stimmt.
... ist, dass diese Art von Verbesserung in keinster Weise den Geist des Klassikers, seine Stärken, seinen Tiefgang irgendwie verschlechtert, verblödet...
Ja, ich gebe ihm recht, aber es ist ja gut jetzt mit Steuerung.
... Empire's 2 Definitive Edition, die für mich der Goldstandard geworden ist, was eine gute Neuauflage angeht.
Denn die baut jede Menge Komfortfeatures an allen Ecken ein.
Es gibt mehr Optionen, mehr Hotkeys, neue Anzeigen, bessere Tutorials.
Haufenweise Upgrades, um das Spiel zugänglicher und besser kontrollierbar zu machen.
Das hätte ich auch nicht gedacht.
Ich meine, ich bin ja da in dieser Zeit mit aufgewachsen, wo diese Games rausgekommen sind.
Ich hätte nie gedacht, dass man 20 Jahre später immer noch sagt, das ist das beste Spiel seiner Art.
Ich meine, ihr werdet nicht wenige Leute finden, die sagen, 2D-Strategiespiele ist Age of Empires 2 das Beste, was es je gegeben hat.
Das hätte ich nie gedacht.
Das hätte ich nie gedacht, dass das, dass ich quasi das Spiel, was ich damals spiele, 20 Jahre später für viele Leute immer noch das Beste seiner Art ist.
Hätte ich nicht vermutet.
Und niemand hat sich da gedacht, ey, nee, also ein wichtiger Teil von Age of Empires 2 damals war doch, dass ich keinen Button hatte, mit dem ich dauerhaft unbegrenzt Felder neu aussehen konnte.
Ich will alle Felder manuell einreihen.
Das stimmt.
Wie früher. Das war eine Kernstärke des Spiels.
Nee, Quatsch.
Age of Empires 2 ist immer noch ein tiefes, anspruchsvolles, komplexes RTS, das nur davon profitiert, wenn ich diese Komplexität besser handhaben kann.
Das macht das Spiel nicht dümmer, das macht es einfach nur besser.
Und man sieht ja, dass die Definitive Edition begeistert aufgenommen wurde, sowohl von neuen Spielern als auch von Oldschool-Veteranen.
Niemand hat sich beschwert darüber, dass das Spiel in diesem Bereich verbessert würde.
Und in meinen Augen sollte Diablo 2 sich davon eine Scheibe abschneiden.
Gibt ja auch keinen Sinn.
Und ebenfalls vom Komfort Verbesserungen anstreben.
Deswegen würde ich unterm Strich sagen, Grund Nummer 1, dem Original treu zu bleiben, ist ehrenwert und wichtig, in diesem Fall aber nicht anwendbar.
Denn meiner Meinung nach ist Bedienkomfort eben kein Bereich, wo man so nah wie möglich am Original bleiben sollte, selbst wenn das heißt, eine veraltete und schlechte Mechanik zu bewahren.
Ja, das stimmt, das stimmt.
Aber Maurice, ich hab's jetzt verstanden.
Ja.
Ich seh's genauso, ich hab's verstanden.
Wir sind einer Meinung.
Ich hoffe, er erzählt jetzt auch was anderes.
Einfach nur, weil das halt früher so war.
Grund Nummer 2, warum die Entwickler sich gegen diese Verbesserungen sperren könnten, ist, dass sie behaupten, sie wollen dem Original treu bleiben, das in Wirklichkeit aber nur als Ausrede nutzen, weil sie sich die Arbeit nicht machen wollen.
Nee, ich glaube wirklich, dass das anders ist.
Ich glaube, sie haben teilweise gar nicht mehr so wirklich das tiefere Verständnis, was die Essenz des Originals ausgemacht hat.
Das ist die Nummer, die Blizzard bei seiner letzten großen neuen Folge abgezogen hat.
Ja, Warcraft.
Deforged.
Bei Warcraft 3 Reforged.
Da haben sie uns das Blaue vom Himmel versprochen, neue Zwischensequenzen, neue Storylines, verbesserte Missionen und das dann alles zurückgefahren mit der Begründung,
die Oldschool-Fans wollten gar nicht, dass wir uns zu weit vom Original entfernen.
Aber heute wissen wir ja, das war totaler Quatsch.
Denn die Oldschool-Fans wollten sicher auch nicht, dass ihr sogar Features rausnehmt, die das Original hatte, das Spiel rausballert und es danach in der Versenkung...
By the way, gibt es eigentlich mittlerweile einen gescheiten Ladder-Modus in Deforged?
Ich weiß nur, dass die ganzen richtig guten Spieler spielen über so eine Third-Party-Seite.
...winden lässt.
Das ist, was Blizzard da gemacht hat und da wissen wir, es ging nie darum...
Ich meine das ernst, ich habe das nicht gespielt, das Remake.
Ihr habt einfach irgendwie mittendrin gemerkt, ihr wollt doch nicht so viele Ressourcen in dieses komische RTS investieren, weil sich das wahrscheinlich eh nicht gut genug verkaufen wird.
Die Sache ist, das will ich den Machern von Diablo Central Directed eigentlich gar nicht vorwerfen, denn nach allem, was man bislang gesehen hat...
Ja, der Story-Modus ist okay.
Wobei ich ganz ehrlich...
Äh...
Irgendwie hatten die Remake-Figuren nicht für mich den Charme des Originals, wobei das Original sehr klötzchenmäßig war.
Ja, das gebe ich schon zu.
Aber die Story ist ja nun wirklich eines der besten Sachen, die Games je auf die Reihe bekommen haben.
Leider haben sie damals...
Oh, wie hieß das Addon nochmal? Frozen? Frozen Throne? Ja.
Haben sie leider ein bisschen auf Sparflamme produziert damals, ohne ordentliche Zwischensequenzen und sonst was.
Weil es schnell raus musste.
Also, Warcraft 3 hätte eigentlich nur noch besser sein können, rein für Singleplayer.
Hätten sie sich bei der Erweiterung vielleicht ein halbes Jahr mehr Zeit gelassen.
Sehr viel Liebe und Herzblut in diese Neuauflage rein.
Man sieht das an der großartig neu aufgelegten Grafik.
Man sieht das daran, dass sie sich im Gegensatz zu Warcraft 3 Reforged auch die Mühe machen, alle Render-Videos neu aufzulegen.
Und die sehen fantastisch aus.
Man sieht das daran, dass sie ja auch Verbesserungen reinbringen.
Wie zum Beispiel die Gamepad-Steuerung, die ich super finde.
Und einige andere Dinge auch an verschiedenen Ecken.
Also es wird ja verbessert, die Entwickler tun da einiges.
Und sie haben auch davor schon gezeigt, dass sie solche Neuauflagen mit viel Respekt und viel Liebe angehen.
Sie haben davor die Tony-Hawks-Spiele neu aufgelegt und auch da einen großartigen Job gemacht.
Also das sind Entwickler, die ihre Neuauflagen mit Herzblut, mit Liebe, mit Aufwand angehen.
Sehr gut.
Und Respekt vor dem Original haben.
Ich glaube eher, dass es andere Gründe sind, die sie hier dazu verleitet haben, keine Veränderung anzustreben.
Zum einen vielleicht ein wenig fehlgeleitet.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich habe es jetzt verstanden mit der Steuerung.
Respekt vor dem Original in diesem konkreten Fall.
Zum anderen vielleicht aber auch Grund Nummer 3.
Die Angst vor den Hardcore-Fans.
Und damit meine ich Choristen, für die erstmal jede Änderung an Diablo ist.
Ja gut, also die gibt es natürlich.
Aber wer sich da bei der Steuerung meckert, das könnte man ja tatsächlich relativ einfach handhaben.
Wenn einer die alte Steuerung haben will, dann kannst du einfach eine Option einbauen.
Weil die ist ja da.
Diablo 2 neumodisches Teufelszeug ist.
Und ich kann das gut nachvollziehen.
Okay, ich glaube reicht jetzt.
Ich habe es verstanden, ich gebe ihm recht.
Ja.
Sehe ich ähnlich.
Ich kenne das Problem, das habe ich manchmal bei Videos auch.
Dass ich so viel zu einem Thema sagen will, aber es ist oftmals eigentlich...
Er bringt ja schon neue Sachen, aber es ist oftmals so der gleiche Kram immer wieder.
Das Problem habe ich auch manchmal.
Ich ertappe mich auch manchmal dabei, wenn ich 16 Minuten Videos aufnehme und mir denke, im Prinzip hätte er das auch alles in 5-6 Minuten erzählen können.
Wobei er sich das im Vorfeld sicherlich auch alles schön überlegt hat, was er da sagt.
Deswegen, ich gucke eigentlich nur noch die Videos von Maurice.
Die anderen interessieren mich nicht so sehr von der Gamestar.
So.
Gucken wir uns den jetzt an.
Advanced Shit Techniques and Shortcuts.
Advanced Big Big Server.
Was gibt es da zu sehen?
Ja gut, so sieht das aus.
Das ist ein alter IBM Server.
Ja, so welche hatten wir auch jede Menge früher.
4 HE Kiste würde ich sagen.
Richtig, richtig schön oldschool noch mit...
VGA und sowas.
Ja.
Hier unten ist die Warnungs-LED, die leuchtet, wenn das Ding Probleme hat.
X3850, ja davon hatten wir auch jede Menge.
Ganz wichtig bei IBM, irgendwo steht die... steht die...
Fru-Nummer drauf.
Die Fru-Nummer ist ganz wichtig bei IBM.
Ja, CD-Players haben die heute immer noch.
Das ist die Service-Nummer, die du angeben musst beim Support, wenn du Ersatzteile brauchst.
Fru-Nummer.
Ja.
Laden.
Blitz.
Stream down.
He lacks critical information.
Ja, das waren so die Einschubskarten, das gab es damals.
Nix neues.
Ja.
Kühlung.
Ja übrigens, so hat man damals Multicore gemacht, ne.
Wie lange geben die Ersatzteile aus?
Nicht so lange.
Die Dinger sind hinüber.
Da kriegst du nichts mehr von.
Nichts mehr für paar Jahre, aber nicht lange.
Also es ist jetzt nicht so, als hätten die da irgendwie 30 Jahre Support oder sowas.
Da auch nicht so.
Paar Jahre, dann ist es vorbei.
So.
Ähm.
Ja, so hast du damals Multicore gemacht.
Da hast du einfach vier CPUs drinne, wenn du vier Kerne gebraucht hast.
Easy.
I have a single CPU now, but remember...
Ah ja, und wie das Ganze gekühlt wird, ist eigentlich relativ einfach.
Das ist ja hier oben zu.
Hier hinten hast du fette Lüfter und je nachdem machst du vorne nochmal Lüfter.
Und das zieht einfach kalte Luft durch.
Ehm.
Je nachdem wie rum du es einbaust.
Und transportierst über die Klimaanlage ab.
Also auf der einen Seite ist warme Luft, auf der anderen Seite ist kalte Luft.
Deswegen klappt das im Rechenzentrum auch so gut mit der Kühlung in dieser Bauweise.
.
Ähm, warte mal. Wie hieß das? RSA hieß das glaub ich. Das IBM Remote Management Ding.
Ilo ist HP, RSA ist IBM, iTrack ist Dell, glaube, wenn ich das richtig aus dem Kopf zusammenkriege.
Hast du die Einschübe für die ganzen Karten?
Das sind übrigens Netzteile, die man tauschen kann.
Da klappst du das Ding hoch und dann kannst du das Netzteil rausziehen.
Und entweder hat es zwei oder vier Netzteile, je nachdem, ich erkenne es jetzt nicht so genau.
Da kannst du Netzteile rausziehen und tauschen im laufenden Betrieb.
Das ist eigentlich ganz nice gemacht.
Das könnten Platesender von hinten sein, ist es aber nicht.
Aber so ein bisschen war es in die Richtung.
Das ist von den Farben her aber dann eher HP.
Aber in der Regel früher war es so, schwarz und ein bisschen blau war IBM.
Dieses komische schwarz und rot war HP und Dell ist so silber.
Und manchmal ein bisschen rot.
Es könnte ich eigentlich auch mal zeigen bei uns unten.
Ich habe ja sogar mit Felix da mal was aufgenommen, fällt mir gerade ein.
Leute, ich sage euch, es ist richtig abfuck, wenn ihr im Rechenzentrum so Dinge einbauen müsst.
Das sind ja die Leisten dafür und wenn es dann klemmt, so ein Ding wie ich keine Ahnung.
50 Kilo oder so bestückt.
Das ist nicht ohne.
Ja, die Dinger gab es ja auch noch.
Konntest du rausklipsen und dann gucken, was kaputt ist.
Das sind schon coole Dinger gewesen, die sie da gebaut haben.
Egal, wir sind vorbei.
Shit, wir gucken uns jetzt Advanced Shit Tricks an.
Get good at git.
A few things are more scary for a software engineer,
than screwing up.
You need to learn something up with Git.
After weeks of writing the perfect code, you submit a pull request
and end up with a bunch of embarrassing failed checks and merge conflicts.
Next thing you know, you're screwed.
Ja und?
Grambling on Stack Overflow, looking for a solution
that will likely just add gasoline to the fire.
Git was created by...
Merge-Konflikte ist, glaube ich, von allen Versionsverwaltungssystemen in Git noch am einfachsten zu handeln.
...a guy much smarter than us.
He knew if he made it too easy, it would make us weak.
Instead, he wanted to give us the glory of overcoming the challenge.
Shit.
Morgen, KS.
I'm pretty sure that's what he was thinking.
In today's video, we'll look at a bunch of different tips and tricks to make you more productive with Git.
But if you're new to Git, I just released a short course on Fireship.io,
that's designed as a modern learning path to get you started with Git and GitHub.
It contains a bunch of short videos along with exercises to transform you into a professional Git user quickly.
Shit.
This content is supported by viewers like you.
And I want to send a huge thank you to everybody out there who's already a pro member.
So, to get started, I'm assuming you know the basics of Git.
Ihr müsst euch einfach merken, Git push master minus minus force.
Easy.
Nein, wenn ihr dann ordentlich Atmen habt und je nachdem wie das ist, dürft ihr wahrscheinlich gar nicht so direkt dahin pushen.
...the basics of Git.
Like you know how to do a Git add followed by a Git commit to save a snapshot of your code.
That's usually the first thing you learn in Git, but there's actually a better way to get the job done.
You can get rid of the Git add...
Git commit A minus M.
...and go straight to commit...
Ja.
...using the AM file.
Okay.
This will automatically add all the files in the current file.
Okay, noch ist er nicht advancer als ich, das wusste ich, das wusste ich noch.
Okay.
Erste, erste Advance Stufe erklommen.
...working directory.
That's a nice improvement, but there's actually an even more concise way to get the job done.
Your Git config provides a way to create aliases, which are...
Ja, hab ich, hab ich auch, aber nicht für commit.
Ich hab beispielsweise für, äh, Branch switchen, ist Git CO bei mir.
...are commonly used to shorten...
Anstatt checkout.
...or create...
Wobei, wobei Git switch...
Das ist ja das neue Git checkout, ist...
...begeistert, wo der Unterschied ist.
...your own new custom commands.
For example, we might create an alias called ac, that runs the add and commit command with just two letters.
Ja, könnte man machen, hab ich aber nicht.
...but sometimes going fast leads to mistakes.
Clearly mistakes were made.
What if you made a typo on your last commit message?
Amend.
Instead of resetting and creating a new commit...
Ja.
...the amend flag followed by a new message...
...will simply update the latest commit.
Das kenn ich auch schon.
...or maybe you forgot to include or stage a couple files with your last commit.
You can also update the last commit...
...with new files by using the amend flag.
And if you want to keep the same commit message, add the no-edit flag as well.
But keep in mind, this only really works if you haven't already pushed your code to a remote repository.
Unless you like to live dangerously.
In which case, you can do a git push with the force flag.
This will overwrite the remote commit...
...with the state of your local code.
Aber nur, wenn man das darf.
...however, if there are commits on the remote branch that you don't have...
Deswegen ist es sinnvoller, man macht es in einem Feature-Branch anstatt im Master-Branch.
Da kann man nämlich rumwursten...
...wie man will, ohne dass man irgendjemand beeinflusst.
...you will lose them forever.
And your co-workers might not be too happy about that.
Don't make me swing on you, bro.
But what happens if you push some code to a remote repository...
...then realize it's complete garbage...
...and never should have been there in the first place.
The git revert command allows you to take one commit...
...and go back to the state...
Das stimmt übrigens überhaupt nicht, dass es undo macht.
git revert macht ein neues commit...
...mit einem quasi umgedrehten div.
Das ist nicht, dass das alte undut wird und ein neues dafür erstellt wird.
Das denken viele.
Du machst ein neues commit obendrauf...
...was einfach nur die Sachen umgedreht quasi wieder entfernt...
...die du vorher hinzugefügt hast.
Aber die commits sind alle noch da.
...that was there previously.
It's kind of like an undo...
...but it doesn't remove the original commit...
...from the history.
Instead it just goes back to the original state...
...and that's much easier than trying to put things back together...
...like a trauma surgeon.
It's too much blood, I can't see a thing.
In other cases, you may need to work on a repo...
...but not have access to your local machine.
If you're at your grandma's house without your laptop...
...you can use any computer that has a web browser.
Go to GitHub and find the repo that you want to work on...
...then hit the period key on your keyboard.
And like magic, it pulls up a browser-based version of VS Code...
...where you can make edits, submit pull requests...
...and do almost anything else you could do...
Hab ich noch nie verwendet. Hab ich jetzt schon öfters gesehen, dass es das gibt.
Ich mein, passt ja. GitHub ist von Microsoft.
Wishlist Studio Code ist von Microsoft.
Dass das immer mehr zusammenwächst, wundert mich nicht.
Habe ich aber selbst noch nicht verwendet.
Doch, du kannst die History ändern, solange es in deinem eigenen Branch ist.
Deswegen sage ich ja Feature praktisch mal.
Stash ist tatsächlich ganz nützlich.
Braucht man nicht oft, aber wenn man es braucht, ist es praktisch, dass es da ist.
Stash braucht man dann, wenn du gerade am Basteln bist...
...und der Chef sagt, ey, kannst du mal kurz ein Fix machen?
Dann machst du git stash, zwischenspeicherst dir alles, was du gerade machst...
...wechselst den Branch, machst eine Fix, gehst wieder zurück...
...machst ein stash pop und machst weiter an der Stelle, wo du gewesen bist.
Und du willst nicht, dass deine Freunde es noch nicht sehen.
git stash wird die Veränderungen aus deiner aktuellen Arbeitsdirektorie entfernen...
...und sie für späteres Benutzen retten.
Ohne sie zu der Repo zu verabschieden.
Die einfachste Art, sie zu nutzen, ist git stash und dann git pop...
...wenn du bereit bist, diese Veränderungen zurück in deinen Code zu geben.
Aber wenn du den Begriff oft benutzt, kannst du git stash save...
...verfolgt von einem Namen, um es später zu beurteilen.
Dann, wenn du bereit bist, wieder daran zu arbeiten, nutze git stash list...
...um es zu finden, dann git stash apply...
...mit dem korrespondienten Index, um es zu benutzen.
Wenn du jetzt eine Stash benutzen willst, bist du fast ein Sol.
Außer du nutzt ein GitHub-Codespace, in dem Falle, dass deine Stashe...
...in der Cloud gespeichert werden würden.
Das ist ziemlich cool.
Aber jetzt habe ich ein öffentliches Service-Erkennung...
...für Entwickler in der modernen Ära.
Historisch ist die Default-Branche in git...
...die Master-Branche genannt.
Oh je, oh je, triggert, triggert, Leute, ich sehe es schon.
...20, dieser Begriff ist nicht mehr die preferierte Nomenklatur.
Benutze es als main, mega oder mucho, um aus Problemen zu bleiben.
Um es zu verändern, nutze git branch...
...verfolgt von der M-Flagge...
...und rename es zu main.
Oder vielleicht werde kreativ und entwickle deinen eigenen Namen.
Jetzt, ein weiteres Begriff, mit dem du wahrscheinlich...
...familierisch bist, ist git...
Also bei mir auf der Arbeit bleibt es auf jeden Fall auch master...
...viel zu vielen Sachen anpassen müsste...
...wo master hardcoded drinsteht.
...log to view a history of commits.
Würde man jetzt was Neues machen...
...und das heißt defaultmäßig main...
...wird es auch problemlos möglich.
...is that the output is harder and harder to read...
...as your project grows in complexity.
To make the output more readable...
...add the options of graph, one line and decorator...
Ich habe ja ehrlich gesagt, mal ganz im Ernst...
...ich habe bis heute nicht so genau die Aufregung...
...um master nachvollziehen können.
Ich weiß weshalb, warum.
Ganz nachvollziehen konnte ich...
...das nicht.
Aber gut.
Wenn die Mehrheit das so will, dann...
...ja.
...beinetwegen.
...a more concise breakdown...
...and how different branches connect together.
But if you're looking at the git log...
...there's likely a commit in there...
...that's currently breaking your app.
git bisect...
Oh ja!
...allows you to...
Das ist schön!
Da kann man relativ einfach die commits rausfinden...
...wo was kaputt gegangen ist.
Binarysearch muss es immer weiter halbieren.
...start from a commit...
...that is known to have a bug...
...likely the most recent commit...
...but you knew that the app...
...was working a few hours ago.
You can point bisect...
...to the last known working commit.
Wie lang brauchst du...
...im schlechtesten Fall...
...mit binarysearch...
...bis du das commit gefunden hast, Leute?
Big-Brain-Informatiker-Stelzer am Start hier.
Binarysearch-Laufzeit...
...richtig.
Ich seh schon...
...wir haben 500 Leute im Chat.
...working commit...
...then it performs a binarysearch...
...to walk you through each commit in between.
If the commit looks good...
...type bisect good...
...to move on to the next commit.
Eventually you'll find the bad one...
...and know exactly which code...
...needs to be fixed.
Another advanced git-technique...
...that every developer should know...
...is how to squash their commits.
Imagine you're working on a feature branch...
Ich muss ehrlich sagen...
...ich resette immer...
...und mach dann ein komplett neues commit.
Weil...
...meine ganzen commits sind...
...wenn ich irgendwas entwickle...
...oftmals ziemlich kacke.
Ja...
...keck w...
...lull...
...eins...
...test...
...was auch immer...
...da kann ich überhaupt nichts mit anfangen.
Ich resette die immer...
...soft reset...
...auf das erste commit...
...und mach dann ein ordentliches...
...ordentlichen...
...ordentlichen commit draus.
...that has three different commits...
...and you're ready to merge it...
...into the master branch.
I mean main branch.
But all these commit messages...
...are kinda pointless...
...and it would be better...
...if it was just one single commit.
We can do that...
...from our feature branch...
...by running git rebase...
...with the interactive option...
...for the main branch.
That'll pull up a file...
...with a list of commits...
...on the screen.
If we want to use a commit...
...we can just use that pick command.
We can also change a message...
...using the reword command...
...or we can combine...
...or squash everything...
...into that original commit...
...using squash.
Go ahead and save the file...
...and close it...
...and git will pull up...
...another file...
...prompting you to update...
...the commit message...
...which by default...
...will be a combination...
...of all the messages...
...that you just squashed.
And if you don't like...
...all the messages to be combined...
...you can use fixup...
...instead of squash...
...when doing the rebase.
To be even more productive...
...you can also use fixup...
...and squash flags...
...when making commits...
...on your branch.
When you do that...
...it tells git in advance...
...that you want to squash them...
...so when you go to do a rebase...
...with the autosquash flag...
...it can handle all the squashing...
...automatically.
Now, if you maintain a repo...
...one tool that can be very useful...
...is githooks.
Whenever you...
Wir haben ja unser Repo...
...mittlerweile auf einem...
...Atlassian Bitbucket liegen...
...bei uns in der Arbeit...
...und...
...ich habe noch...
...uh...
...nicht mehr...
hidden Git-Directory, you'll see a directory there called hooks. And inside of it, you'll
find a bunch of different scripts that can be configured to run when different events
in Git happen. If you happen to be a JavaScript developer, there's a package called Husky
that makes it much easier to configure Git-Hooks.
Also das letzte, woran ich gedacht habe bei Git-Hooks ist, ha, scheiße, dass ich die
nicht in JavaScript programmieren kann.
For example, you might install it with NPM, then create a script that will validate or
lint your code before each commit. And that can help improve your overall code quality.
To wrap things up, let's talk about deleting things. Let's imagine you have a remote repository
Nee, hab's vergessen. Du kriegst einmal publishte Sachen eigentlich so gut wie nie
wieder weg.
...on your machine that you've been making changes to, but things haven't been going
too well. And you just want to go back to the original state in the remote repo.
Ja gut, das geht. Das geht. Aber den Comet aus dem Internet rauszubekommen, wenn irgendwie
Leute schon gepostet haben, ist nicht so einfach.
Ja, das geht.
...to override your local code with the remote code. But be careful, your local changes will
be lost forever. But you might still be left with some random, untracked files...
Na, das stimmt nicht. Die lokale Changes sind nicht forever weg, dafür gibt's RevLog, was
er jetzt gar nicht drin hat. RevLog ist eines der besten Git-Hackern in Sachen.
...but if you're sick of Git at this point and want to just get rid of it altogether, maybe you want to try out
Apache Subtracts.
...to change things up a bit. All you have to do is delete the hidden Git folder and you're on your own again.
Oh, and there's one other tip I almost forgot about that comes in really handy. If you recently switched
out of a branch and forgot its name, you can use git checkout followed by a dash to go directly back
into the previous branch that you were working on. I'm gonna go ahead and wrap things up there.
If you have any additional Git-Tips, make sure to leave them in the comments.
Leute, RevLog ist das...
...and if you want to master the fundamentals of Git step by step, check out the full course on
Fireship.io. Thanks for watching.
...Git RevLog.
Das ist das Beste, wenn ihr irgendwas gelöscht habt und es wiederhaben wollt.
Das Log, das ist eine History aller eurer Kommandos, die ihr in eurem Repo gemacht habt.
Unabhängig davon, ob ihr Comets gelöscht habt oder was auch immer. Solange euer Git-Ordner
noch intakt ist und ihr das nicht aufgeräumt habt oder weggeschmissen habt, ist alles
noch da.
Excellent, excellent.
Aber ich muss noch kurz gucken.
Steam Battlefield 3 Stats.
Wie viele Leute spielen da?
Oh, doch so viele.
Oh, ganze 117, der Wahnsinn.
Jaja, es wurde ja über Steam rausgebracht.
Ich meine, die meisten werden über Origin spielen, aber es ist halt der Trend, es zu
erkennen.
Wann startet die Beta?
Das weiß ich offiziell nicht.
Ich würde mal vermuten, irgendwann Ende des Monats.
Ich rate jetzt einfach mal.
Doch, dann wird auch Origin gestartet, aber es trackt trotzdem über Steam Stats, wer
Steam gestartet hat.
Wann würdest du mir empfehlen, einen Tag Urlaub in diesem Garnet?
Ich nehme für die Battlefield-Beta auch keinen Urlaub.
Better than Stack Overflow.
Stack Overflow driven, beste.
Sometimes when I see code like this, I wonder, damn, this looks very complicated.
How does this person know how to install Chrome from these URLs?
Gar nicht, der hat Stack Overflow.
And then all of these flags, like why call it Chrome with specifically these
arguments?
Like, how would I come up with this?
And here's the trick, how I do this.
I go to grab that app and I know I want, so I would search, for example, for
something like this.
Google Chrome, then probably I will restrict it.
Das ist quasi Google Code Search, nur in jetzt funktionierend.
Something like Dockerfile.
And then I have a huge collection of example repository codes where people use
Chrome.
Headless or something in a Dockerfile.
Ich muss auch immer nachgucken.
Es gibt so viele Sachen, die ich mir nicht merken kann.
Nee, die GitHub-Suche ist nicht so der Wahnsinn.
Zum Beispiel, dass du auf der GitHub-Suche nicht gescheit Substrings und so suchen kannst.
Das ist alles.
So here, for example, somebody has a Dockerfile that has Chrome.
And then you see here some basic endpoints.
You know, you see them.
Ja, gut, aber den Service kannte ich tatsächlich noch nicht.
Das sieht nicht, sieht nicht schlecht aus.
Leute, ich habe Hunger.
Ich glaube, ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Eventuell machen wir heute Abend nochmal streamen oder auch nicht.
Ich weiß es noch nicht genau.
Können wir gucken.
Ich weiß, ich habe die letzten Tage wenig, wenig gestreamt und auch wenig Videos gemacht.
Ich muss jetzt erst mal neues Vid aufnehmen und schauen, dass ich wieder contentmäßig was produziert kriege.
Ja.
Schauen wir mal.
Hast du einen TS-100-Lötkolben?
Nein.
Ich habe eine Lötstation von Erza.
Versuch doch mal Content aus dem Stream.
Was soll ich denn da hochladen?
Ich kann ja schlecht Reaction hochladen.
Max reacted auf.
Mach einen Reaction-Bot, der selbst Reactions aus dem Stream auf YouTube hochladen kann.
Oh, five hat time.
Zibo, danke für den Sub.
Okay, Leute.
Ich gehe jetzt was futtern.
Wir sehen uns.
Bis dann.
Macht's gut.
See you.